need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best tony robbins
and my take on his top 50 rules for
success
enjoy
the most common question i've been asked
by the media in my entire life that
always makes me laugh is well don't you
have bad days don't you have days when
you're like frustrated excited and
pissed off and you watch tv and you eat
cheetos and watch pornography and i said
well i do some of those things
and of course i do but when i it's like
an athlete i've built muscle over the
years so that it's not that i don't have
feelings i don't get hurt i don't feel
sad i don't feel tired all those things
but they're not the dominant force in my
life it's a muscle the mind is a muscle
emotion is a muscle i mean i think the
most powerful muscles are the invisible
force muscles it's your spiritual
emotional muscles like courage unused
doesn't grow it shrinks so i put my ass
on the line regularly so that it grows
and when it keeps growing then pretty
soon the stuff that used to make me
crazy it doesn't touch me it's not that
i'm so great just i'm well trained i've
trained this mind i get up every morning
in my life you can talk about rebounder
more crazy [ __ ] i ideas everywhere in my
life if i'm near if i'm near any of my
homes and some places i have i have
cryotherapy but my homes i have these
cold plungers and they're 56 degrees and
the first thing i do is jump in that
cold point so there's not a morning
where i want to jump in that i can't
remember where he's like i can't wait to
jump in that thing but i don't negotiate
with myself i do it for two reasons one
there's a physical health component it
moves your lymph system and the blood
flushes through your whole body but the
main reason i do it even more than that
is when i go up there i don't you know
people negotiate well i'm able to do it
tomorrow i'm going to do this or i'll
let me like two more minutes until i'm
ready there's none of that with me for
decades i go i say we do i'm not here to
discuss this [ __ ] with my mind there's
mind and then there's soul and spirit
and soul and spirit my soul knows and
when i say jump you jump i'm not here to
have a discussion with you i always tell
people uh anticipation is power if you
ever play a video game against a child
that's pretty disastrous right maybe not
for you or maybe a different generation
but for me it's like you know it's not
the kids faster and smarter if they
played this game before like eight
million times so they know the first
shots here the second shot third shot
there and you're like reacting so when
you're reacting to things you fail so my
mentors have been people over the years
different people my earliest mentor was
a man named jim rohn he was a personal
development speaker just touched my life
then i was involved in neuro-linguistic
programming nlp when i was
21 22 23 years old i became partners
with a man named john grinder brilliant
man co-founder of that
but in my last couple decades it's been
people like peter guber who's owns the
the la dodgers and and owns uh you know
the golden state warriors nba team and
he's just got 52 academy award
nominations so he's a mentor for me um
paul tudor jones i coach but also i'm
coached by him because we get to pitch
and catch um and then you know i've got
some people in my life that you know
like steve wynn is a dear friend of mine
most of las vegas he's brilliant and
these guys are all 18 years my senior so
they know the road ahead and i'm able to
learn from them in advance and kind of
anticipate things and that to me is
incredibly valuable yeah what is the one
thing that you want people to understand
about control when they feel out of
control they feel they don't understand
the stock market like what's the one
message you want to you want people to
take home around control
i think it's uh that you have to become
an owner and not just a consumer you
have to take a percentage of what you
earn as simplistic as it sounds and
automate it so it comes off the top of
what you earn uh there's a gentleman
that used work for ups names theodore
and theodore robinson was this guy who
never made more than fourteen thousand
dollars a year and yet he retired with
70 million dollars and gave away 35
million while he's alive how did he do
it he became an owner his best friend
said to him listen to me the most
important thing in your life is we're
going to put a wealth tax on you because
your wealth tax i think 14 000 a year he
goes we're going to make you wealthy
with this tax it's not a government
taxes tax for yourself so we're going to
take 20 of what you earn and put it in
investment account let it build up he
said i can't afford that he goes once
it's automated you won't notice
that's all he did that made him 70
million dollars so it's like people have
to understand that no matter how good
you are in business we all need a second
business with no employees and it takes
very little time something that once you
do your homework should take you you
know 15 minutes to an hour twice a year
to rebalance perhaps but outside of that
that's what this is this is setting up a
business that'll make you do well when i
was um how do i was 20
24 years old 25 years old i worked with
a man named ken blanchard who wrote
those one minute manager books you
probably remember him evan yeah
really great guy and he i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game and
that made me god to him so
and then he said i want to return the
favor and he goes the best advice i got
growing my business was i was about to
come out with my first book
and he said a friend of mine is very
wealthy said do not put that money in
your company let the leads go to your
company do not let the profits go and do
not spend those profits put that in a
separate account that nothing ever
touches because your business will eat
whatever resources you have what a
growing business does that and he said
tony i put that aside and during the
tough times that's what made me safe
well i did the same thing with that in
my original infomercials
that alone made me a wealthy man so when
tough times came i could withstand it so
i see so many business owners go yeah
but i have control of my business
[ __ ] you have influence over your
business yes you have more influence but
there are better entrepreneurs than you
perhaps out there as well or businesses
that get greater valuations in your
business will and so your ability to
grow you want to grow your own business
i always tell people you want to build
two businesses the business you're in
the business you're becoming and that
you want to have the business that
you're in and becoming in an investment
business it's really simple once you set
it up and i think everybody's got to do
that if they really want to have
financial freedom because look the
marketplace changes competition changes
ibm was the head of the pack forever and
then some little kid from microsoft
comes along and buys ms-dos for fifty
thousand dollars and then leases it to
them and makes himself three billion on
that little move alone he didn't even
write their software right you know he's
doing great and all of a sudden you know
this little company comes along a couple
of guys at stanford called google you
know and apple comes along so there's
always disruption and the disruption can
be competition it can be new technology
it could be a change in the culture so
even if you do everything right you
could lose i want people to have a
back-up plan this is the back-up plan
why is lebron james who he is it's not
because he's lucky in other words say
you know he's lucky
he might have certain physical factors
or michael jordan i remember i
interviewed him years ago
and i said what makes you the best in
the world is it skill is it talent is it
ability is it background is in training
and he was so awesome he said tony i can
tell you the truth and it won't sound
like hyperbole or false modesty he said
i didn't even make the high school
basketball team my sophomore year i was
cut
he said what it is is every day i demand
more for myself than anybody else could
possibly expect i don't compete with
other people i compete with what i'm
capable of and there's just like that
kind of standard is inspiring also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
breakdowns it's certainly not something
i experienced but it's not because i'm
so talented or so brilliant or so
fearless it's just
you're like an athlete you're an athlete
yeah you're in shape right you're not
going to have a reaction in your body
like somebody who doesn't take care of
themselves right so you know i believe i
don't believe in emotional intelligence
i think it's useful but i'm more
interested in emotional fitness because
intelligence is a capability fitness is
a state of readiness interesting if you
are fit you can take that demand right
now you can deal with it you can deal
with that physical stress that emotional
stress same thing's true with
psychological fitness emotional fitness
right so i'm pretty fit and part of that
is not because i'm so smart part of this
i i've taught this for decades i
remember i had a woman who came on my
seminars in um in her i don't know early
80s probably and she would run in this
room five ten thousand people i think
was you know two in a couple of ten
thousand person events and she would get
in this front row fight her way through
there and she'd jump and go for it at
one break she came up to signing a book
for her and she says she goes mr adams
i've seen you at like eight of these
i've seen you like when you're really i
know i can hear your voice you're
hurting or you haven't slept and she
goes you always seem to be so up all the
time how can you sew up and i said well
part because i attend all these seminars
yeah so i'm teaching it so there's a
fitness of that there's also you know
i've i've buried three fathers and and
one mother and you know that affects
your life i've uh you know i've had a
physician look me in the eye and say you
have a tumor in your brain wow and so
i've had those moments that
when you've had extreme stress
and you push your way through it you
build psychological muscle it's like it
takes a lot to knock me off you know in
the early days we didn't have 50 000
keep the doors open how do we do it then
i had you know graduated to 5 million
then i graduated to uh a partner that
mine who kind of didn't do things well
and i ended up owning 100 million
dollars because i had to take on his
debts 100 million dollars
and but when you do all that stuff you
know now my companies do 5 billion you
know a year so uh
you you keep expanding what i would call
really the circle of your the threshold
of your influence sure you know
everybody has a threshold of control and
if you get beyond it you kind of freak
out so
it takes a little bit more i don't know
i guess you don't have breakdowns it's
not a breakdown do i get pissed off or
get frustrated or tired yeah but
breakdown honestly no what would you
tell the startup entrepreneur who maybe
is just getting started or maybe still
has a full-time job and it feels like
every dollar that they're making they're
just trying to build their business at
the moment they haven't cashed out yet
should they be investing into their
business should they still be saving
someone put into the market what would
you tell that person i think you have to
put something outside your business
because what's the number one rule of
investing that even idiots understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what did 90 of entrepreneurs
do because of the illusion of control
they go i'm gonna put all my money in my
business don't get me wrong it's still a
great place for your money and for your
time with your energy but you got to
take a piece of what you earn and you
got to bet on some other entrepreneurs
and get outside yourself specifically
and if you look at you know somebody
like warren buffett will tell you you
know what he said my all my wealth is a
result of a couple things some good
genes and compound interest and living
in america so if all you do is get
compound interest on your side the game
changes you know if you take a 19 year
old kid
that's got a little job and you say look
i want you it sounds like a lot but i
want you to put aside 300 a month let me
show you why 300 bucks a month set aside
thrown in the market average market
return has been eight percent it's been
10 over 100 years but most recent you
know 30 years eight percent
so let's say you get the average return
and it compounds that kid who starts at
19 with 300 a month can stop at 27.
he's only done it for eight years never
put another dime in
and he's only put in 24 or 28 000
but that'll grow to 1.8 million without
putting another diamond that's the power
of compounding 28 grand 1.8 million
if his best friend starts at 27 when he
quits and invests every single year all
the way to 65
and he puts in the same 300 a month he
puts in 140 grand and at that time he's
got 400 000 less money
so it's not the amount of money it's the
amount of time
time is your greatest friend here and if
you get in the game you're gonna win and
you need to get in the game now not wait
til your business is successful so i
live my life where i keep learning i
keep growing i keep loving i keep
laughing and i'm trying to leave a
decent legacy of a meaningful life by
constantly looking for ways i can be
helpful and
my prayer simple prayer before i walk
out on every stage just use me use me
lord and and when you do that it's like
if you get out of the way my greatest
gift is getting out of the way i know
that sounds silly to some people but
it's really true i'm not an ultra
religious person but i'm extremely
spiritual and i believe the force of
life comes through me it comes through
it comes through all of us and the only
thing gets in the way is all the beliefs
we have how it's supposed to be all the
expectations we have and i have them too
but i keep weeding them out sir john
templeton is probably one of the
greatest investors in history people
don't know his name uh he started out
with nothing um he wasn't sir he wasn't
from another country came from the us
and he decided that he wanted to
understand wealth and so he saved ten
thousand dollars a huge amount of money
in those days and when hitler invaded
poland he developed a belief his belief
was you make your money in times of
maximum pessimism like if you were
around a 2008 nine you remember what was
like right
you could have bought you know the sands
in las vegas you could have bought their
stock for two dollars and 28 cents today
at 67 wow it's a 3 000 return not bad um
you could have bought
uh citibank for less than a buck
right so people in those times he
understood that and so what he did was
and everybody thought the world was
gonna end he took ten thousand dollars
he bought every stock on new york stock
exchange it was a dollar or less
including companies everybody thought
we're going bankrupt but we when things
are bad people think it's gonna be bad
forever when things are good they think
it's gonna be good forever and they're
always wrong life's cyclical so there's
a season for everything so once we got
through world war ii and a few years
later guess what those same stocks made
him a billionaire so when i asked him i
said what's the secret to wealth his
responsibility touched me goes you know
it you teach it i said what's that he
said gratitude and so why do you say
that he said because if you got a
billion dollars and every day you live
pissed off and frustrated the quality of
your life is called pissed off and
frustrated
but if you have nothing
but you're euphorically grateful for
whatever you have you're the richest
person that you're gonna know he said so
it doesn't matter how much money you got
if you don't have gratitude so i do the
same thing by the way i have a process i
call it priming where i get up every
morning i do mine in the morning
i just radical change to my body kind of
alter my state and then i do 10 minutes
i never miss and my first three and a
half minutes is what i'm really grateful
for and i make myself think of at least
one of those three that's something
really simplistic there's something
giant you know the wind on my face the
look in one of my kids eyes you know
something of that nature and then i do
three minutes of strengthening healing
and i do three minutes of what i'm going
to create my world and i do that for a
minimum of 10 minutes every day because
i believe you have to condition you
don't just hope that stuff shows up you
set your intention each morning
every day yeah i look at control as a
delusion right that's the first thing
it's your desire for the illusion of
control that's pushing you what you want
is certainty you want certain you can
avoid pain you want certain you can have
pleasure you want certainly you can have
a significant and meaningful life we all
want certainty but
learning ways to control what you can
control is wonderful but you can't
control most things what you can do is
influence them and so what i look at and
say is don't give myself the delusion i
have control because then i'll feel like
i've lost it at some point i never had
control i have influence i can influence
my kids i can't control them i can
influence myself i can influence what
happens to me financially can't control
it completely and so i think if you give
up the illusion of control that loosens
things up a little bit but i think the
second thing is to focus on what you can
control which is what what you think
feel and what you do
and if i focus on the things i can
control i want to feel better i mean all
the research shows
that human beings when they feel out of
control freak out inside and the more
they feel they're in control the greater
their self-esteem the way to have that
additional control is to say okay what i
can control is what i do within the
seasons you can say i don't like gravity
and step off the side here but you're
going to pay the price there are certain
things that are outside your control but
you can use gravity i fly a helicopter
an airplane because i understand the
dynamics of how to do that if you
understand the dynamics of the
marketplace you use the marketplace the
marketplace doesn't use you and that's
why i wrote unshakeable i want people to
have no more fear and when you start
understanding some of these statistics
like what's everybody afraid of a bear
market a bear market is when it you know
market corrects 20 or more
over the last 80 years they've happened
about every three to five years to give
you an idea later years more five years
well now we've gone the longest period
in history without one and yet people
are still afraid after every single bear
market we've had in the history of the
united states it's led immediately into
a bull market if you remember 2008 2009
50 drop in the next 12 months it was up
the s p was up 69
it's almost 70 i can show you every turn
down so when you start seeing that it's
it's immutable it's like winter comes
but winter isn't forever and winter is a
great time to take advantage because
some people freeze to death in winter
other people ski and snowboard and get
by the fire well winter is when things
are on sale if somebody said to you i
got a 400 000 ferrari that you could buy
for seventy thousand dollars you're
probably grabbing a heartbeat but if
somebody takes you a stock that was 400
and 70 bucks you're like oh my god i
can't do this you have to look at the
cycles of history and when you do it you
become unshakable and more importantly
you become wealthy
the very first thing i do when i wake up
in the morning is i want to get my head
right i do this thing called priming now
some people get up in the morning and
they meditate and i think meditation is
wonderful but i haven't met many people
that can not think thoughts this is a
different outcome this is about priming
yourself it's about putting yourself in
the state where your mind and body will
respond accordingly we'll do three steps
it's really simple over 10 minutes so
why don't you sit down and i'll guide
you through it so just get really
comfortable you want to be sitting up is
that back enough for you to be able to
relax yeah good okay cool and then the
first thing you're going to do is your
hands are going to come up as you take
the breath in and then you're going to
explode out the nose down
explosive that's it
good
that's it keep going two more
good now relax keep your eyes closed
have your hands open if you would on
your lap face up like that
just feel whatever you feel
just take it in and you don't have to
respond to me anymore you just enjoy it
and take it in
and now just let your body relax deeply
and i'd like you to
begin to think of a moment in your life
you could feel
really grateful for if you wanted to
it could be something little rich or
could be something big it doesn't matter
it could be from your childhood or this
week it doesn't matter do your best to
remember it and then
step into it as if you were there kind
of like stepping into your body and
seeing what you saw then through your
own eyes hearing what you heard then
feeling what you felt then
savor it
maximize that sense of appreciation or
enjoyment or gratitude
enjoy it
feel it
fill up with it
now we're going to shift to the last
piece really simple all you're going to
do is focus on three things one at a
time that you want to accomplish three
things you want to achieve
live it and feel it and experience it
[Applause]
how was that
yeah what'd you feel
yeah there's two worlds to master the
external world in the internal world
they both have to be mastered but if you
master the external world you know
a la you know robin williams but you
don't master the internal world there's
a big price this is the one to master
first and so i start my day by making
that so i have this base to do it i'm
going to live from gratitude today i'm
going to live from blessing you know i
want to be a blessing in people's life
today i'm going to get stronger today
and i'm going to achieve what i'm here
committed to do and the whole thing you
know we did that one in a little less
than 10 minutes to give you an idea
what made me effective was that i
wouldn't get involved in a business just
to make money i'm involved with the
business because it's a mission it's
something that i think can change
somebody's life and whether it's
something as simple as stem cell
business or whether it's lafc a soccer
team i own uh or whether it's a resort
in fiji i try to do something that's
going to change their lives and the
whole focus in business is add more
value there is no other rule if you do
more for others than anybody else does
in the marketplace you'll build a brand
people get on their knees and reach
behind a soda pop to get a coca-cola
even though coke doesn't win most the
taste test it is the brand you will
become the brand if you can do more for
others than anybody else does and i hope
that your audience the reason they're
listening to you is to figure out how to
add more and more value to the
marketplace what is it that prevents
people from doing the things they
already want to do in life the most
basic answer i'm sorry it's so simple
but it's true it's fear you know people
making this complex process this woman
has told me that i don't understand why
they don't do this why i feel this way
it's called fear everybody's afraid
we're not enough everybody's afraid
we're not rich enough smart enough young
enough quick enough fast enough it's
human nature but the secret is to do it
anyway i know that sounds so simplistic
my work when i'm working with somebody
is showing how to condition themselves
like building a muscle so that you take
action first automatically because if
you don't do that it's hard you lose
momentum it's like how do i get started
where do i go and i tell people throw a
rock wherever it drops start there the
next person walks by i go you're the
first person after the rock do anything
to start the process of moving forward
rather than like fear stop you i
developed this little system and the
system was really simple and i tell
people now as i say number one every
single day you've got to feed and
strengthen your mind
until you do that you're always going to
be unfair because fear is automatic the
human brain is designed for survival
it's not designed for success your brain
is not designed to make you happy that's
your job right the only way we're going
to do it is if you feed your mind
because otherwise weeds grow
automatically by drinking my coach your
mentor jim rohney's telling me so tony
every day you got to stand guard at the
door of your mind you got to watch
what's going on because if you're not
careful stuff will go into if you're
saying all the times it's somebody who
cares about you said you know if you're
you're family yeah yeah if your worst
enemy puts sugar in your coffee he said
what happens i said you got sweet coffee
because we're your best friend by
accident or your family don't mean to
they drop one drop of strychnine on your
coffee you're dead he said so life sugar
and strychnine and watch your coffee
right right so every day i decided i i'm
old enough honestly there was no
internet those days i'm pretty ancient i
used to go to the library because the
only patient go and i would read
biographies i'd read people's lives and
make me go wait a second as bad as i
think it is the greatest people in the
world had it worse sure so there's
something here so you feed your mind i
i'm jim rohn you say to me
skip a meal but don't skip reading i
said read 30 minutes a day i don't give
a damn what it is today i don't mean
internet crap i mean read something a
biography read something that's a
strategy read something's going to
change your life you deserve to be loved
even if you
need to do something for yourself
because real love
doesn't have conditions
real love takes joy when someone is
happy whatever it takes even if it means
being apart from you for a period of
time or even forever
otherwise it's not love
it's the selfish desire to get what you
want whether it makes someone else happy
or not
some of you are in relationships where
you're committed to the ship and not the
relations
you're committed to the institution and
you forgot the person
because you don't even meet the person
anymore you meet your story about the
person because you've told it to
yourself so many times so everything is
seen through that filter
if you think someone is your dear dear
friend and
they're loving and they're generous and
they're a beautiful soul and one day
they treat you like
you'll be shocked and you'll be angry
and if you can't resolve it
and you have to leave to go deal with
something you'll generalize their
behavior later on you'll say they're
probably having a bad
what
how many of you had a day where you hope
somebody generalized your behavior is
just a bad day
but if somebody you think that they
don't care
or they're selfish or they're mean
because you've generalized about the
human being because by the way you can
find selfishness in anybody if you look
for it including yourself
whatever you look for you're going to
find you can you find beauty can you
find love can you find generosity in any
human being yes or no i had a moment
like when my whole life changed it was
kind of twofold i had i was i was really
young like yourself back then right
working my tail off trying to build a
business and you had big goals you know
you don't always succeed to start with
right
together right you know it was hard and
i remember i was so frustrated because i
was working 18-hour days and nothing was
working and i was broke and i felt
embarrassed you know i should be doing
better than this yeah and so i was
driving home from orange county on the
57th freeway in san gabriel valley out
in their place in pomona california
probably not anybody else i remember so
vividly because it was almost midnight
and i was at this breaking point and
then i was like why am i not you know
doing better and then i just pulled over
the road and i used to keep these
journals i still have them written
journals and i wrote in big lines you
know the secret to living is giving and
i started to cry and i realized i am so
focused on what am i not getting i'm not
focusing on what i'm giving yeah so for
six months man it turned me around but
then you know something else i get in
your body it was in my head it was in my
heart but it had to get in there to stay
and i started going through some really
tough times and i lost everything
financially and i was mad at every
because like i've loaned a friend a
thousand bucks and you know i'm doing
well and he didn't return my phone call
oh and what changed me was i i was down
i know 22 23 bucks something like that i
know it's 24
enough that i knew that i didn't have
money for food for the next week clearly
and i didn't have any prospects and i
was living in venice in this 400 square
foot bachelor apartment feeling sorry
for myself
and i thought you know what i got to eat
so i'm not gonna drive my car because
i'm not gonna spend the gas i'm not
gonna pay for parking sure i'm gonna go
to all you can eat place and load up for
the winter right so i can get more like
one meal a day right and so uh
there's a place called marina del rey
not far from venice and it's beautiful
community and it's right on the water
and there's a place called el cerrito
it's still there it's a little uh
restaurant it had taco bar and all that
kind of stuff
so i walked there for the three miles
and i go like i'm gonna go and load up
and i was all about myself and getting
through this
and this little well this woman walked
the door actually very attractive lady
that's probably why i caught my hat and
i'm waiting to see who her boyfriend is
and there's nobody up there there's a
little guy down here he was obviously
her son and he's wearing this
three-piece suit you know a little vest
he opens the door for he pulls out the
chair for her and it was just
he stared at his mother's eyes i mean it
was just pierced into her eyes i don't
know what it was but something about him
was just so moving such a sweet caring
loving young man to his mother that
moved me so i i paid for my meal
and i was left 17 18 bucks put it back
in my pocket was left walked up this
young man introduced myself and i said
hi i don't understand but he says his
name is ronnie and that's ronnie i said
i said you're really i said you're a
class actor i saw you open the door for
your lady i saw you hold out the chair
for your lady goes she's my move
i said that's even more classy right
right and he's and i said so cool that
you're taking that to lunch like this
and he goes well i'm not really taking a
lunch because i'm just 11 and i don't
have a job you know
i said yes you are and i had no plan
literally i just reached in my pocket
took all the money had changed dollar
pills and threw it right there in front
of him he looked at me like this he goes
i can't take that i said sure you can he
said well why i said because i'm bigger
than you
and he got this big grin in his face his
eyes got this big and i didn't i just
shook his hand i didn't even look at
this while his mom and i just walked out
the door but the reason i tell you the
story is
i had no car i had no money
i did not i was euphoric i was like
flying home i was like you know i look
like an idiot probably skipping or
something
i and what i thought was i should have
been like what the hell did you just do
i had no meal what are we gonna eat i
went on that night i laid out a plan and
the plan was gonna take me you know ten
days two weeks so i thought well people
fast for a week i could fast for a week
you know that type of thing and i have
this great mindset about it i woke up
the next morning and i get the old
regular snail mail shows up and it's
this guy i've called a zillion times it
wouldn't return my call open it up
there's a check thousand bucks plus
interest and an apology wow so i'm
sitting there and i started to cry
honestly and i was just like
why did this happen you know and i don't
know if it's true but i decided that day
this happened because i did the right
thing
because i didn't have a plan it wasn't a
strategy i just felt this
little soul beside me i knew it was
right and i did it and i didn't do it
because i thought i could or i couldn't
i didn't even think about it
and
that's the day i became a wealthy man
because i didn't have any money
but scarcity left my body and i had
plenty of ups and downs since that time
and various times of my life but i never
went back to that oh my god you know
how's it gonna happen it's like
breathing do you stop and say god is
there gonna be the air before you take a
breath you know it's gonna be there
right you don't you don't run your life
by that aspect and so that to me is what
it's about is showing people if you
won't give a dime out of a dollar
don't [ __ ] yourself you'll never
give a million out of 10 million or 10
million out of 100 million it's just not
going to happen right but if you can do
that now you you don't ever
get beyond scarcity you start behind it
you you make a decision to get beyond it
how much do you advise understanding the
individual companies or should it just
be kind of set it forget it by the index
looking at once a year then don't worry
about it i don't think you want to just
do the index because you want to have
different asset classes if you look at
the best investors in the world they all
understand that they're going to be
wrong uh you've talked to ray dalio the
greatest hedge fund investor in the
history of the world guy who made a
fortune in 2008 when everyone else is
losing money and what does he tell you
he says tony you have to have money in
each different asset class because
different environments the environments
will change no matter how smart people
think they are they're going to be wrong
and you got to structure yourself so
you're able to make money no matter what
so you don't want just you know the
index but what you do want to do is you
do not want to be probably somebody
who's trying to evaluate individual
stocks that's really you know somebody's
going to try and be a trader and in most
cases that's not going to work now if
you're warren buffett that's a different
piece but maybe better to invest with
warren buffett who's better at selection
than you are than you trying to do it
stock picking nobody wins at it the best
in the world don't win you got people
that are supposed to be the best hedge
fund guys on earth and what's their
track record of the last seven years
it's pathetic they've not even matched
the market right and so that's why
you've seen this shake-up in the hedge
fund industry because after you pay for
fees even with their brilliant minds
you end up lower than if you just own
the market itself so the answer to
question is you need to diversify every
investor believes in diversification
across multiple elements in other words
you don't want to just buy real estate
you want different assets or just the
index like you described that's a
disaster because there'll be times when
the index will get hit and you need
something to balance it out if you're
only in one place you're going to get
hurt and the pain will be so strong
you'll probably sell and then have a
permanent wound or a permanent problem
you don't want that to happen so you
need diversity across different assets
you don't want just one giant piece of
real estate you want diversity within
asset classes so multiple pieces of real
estate or or owning the index is the
example you want diversification across
different economies
and you want diversification across time
and the next time you're throwing a
judgment on someone else remind yourself
why you're doing it
you're doing it because you're uncertain
you're doing because you feel
insignificant
you're doing it for you feel
disconnected but you're the one making
yourself insignificant and uncertain and
disconnected because all that would
disappear if you entered their world and
tried to understand or appreciate not
understand intellectually that's why i
say appreciate what they're going
through
doesn't mean you have to agree with it
but if you appreciate it there'll be
compassion and where there's compassion
there is love
compassion
means you care passionately
that's where it comes from
not really but i made it up it sounded
good didn't it it was really good if
somebody is we're mentioning earlier if
somebody is really stressed out they're
not stressed out for no reason it's
because they're focusing on something
that makes them feel stressed they often
when they're focusing on it it changes
the body you start to feel tight you
start to feel a certain way and then
they use language like i don't know what
to do why am i so overwhelmed so three
things control how you feel every moment
what you focus on what you do with your
body if your shoulders are down if
you're breathing like ah
it's not hard to figure out you're not
going to be in a very resourceful state
if i take that same person and change
their body radically i get them to talk
at a different tempo i get them to move
their body differently i've taught this
for what 41 years three years ago at
harvard they did a study on power
postures where they showed that if you
stand like this with your hands on your
hips like superman or wonder woman or if
you lean back like this like the guy
isn't obnoxious at the office and do
this
it literally changes your testosterone
by 25 within two minutes it reduces
cortisol which you know is the stress
hormone by 30
and you're 33 more likely to take an
action so if we change what we focus on
if we change the way we use our body if
we change our language patterns we'll
instantly feel different things how do
people use their body when they're
worried versus when they're excited if
you learn to use your body first use
your focus first you can literally
change how you feel moments and then you
develop new habits where you start to
feel good all the time and it isn't some
phony fake pump up it's literally the
way you've conditioned your body just
like being fit as an athlete you want to
be emotionally fit there's no way that
you're going to get a secure environment
the whole idea is to build your money up
build your assets up and eventually have
the income take care of you for the rest
of your life the only reason you invest
is for income income will buy you your
trips it'll put your kids through
college they'll pay for your home it'll
give you food people think they want
assets assets can go up and down for any
period of time so you want to put in a
secure place at some point where the
income provides all you need for the
rest of your life well pretty hard to do
that if you're putting down an
environment we're trying to get 10 it's
not going to happen so you really need
20 times your income that's really the
number that most people should be
utilizing it doesn't sound very
compelling but when you understand
compounding like you know 300 a month
for eight years turns into 1.8 million
never put another diamond you start to
go hmm maybe i can still win this game
we don't think geometrically we think
you know step at a time and the way
stocks work or the way any investment
works there's compounding and the
compounding is the greatest gift that we
have my family was fed when i was 11 we
had no food at thanksgiving and
uh it touched me so deeply and i decided
i was going to get back so when i was 17
i fed two families and then four and
then eight and then i didn't tell me i
was doing it and then i got my friends
to do it and my companies grew and you
know i've fed 42 million people now over
37 years
and uh but you have a challenge for this
right
what i did is i decided you know i'm
writing this book and in the middle of
writing it
last summer most people even noticed
congress cut food stamps they don't call
food stamps anymore but i lived on them
so i know what they are food stamps and
my family my family lived on them but
they cut it by 8.7 billion which means
you eliminate 2 million people from the
rolls overnight and they still need to
eat
so i support all these nonprofit
organizations and feeding america is the
largest in the country
and so i thought i want to call
attention to this so if i donated all
the profits in this book in advance how
many people could i feed because i
normally feed two million through my
foundation and i match it so i need four
million a year
and uh they said you could feed 10
million people i was like wow i mean
and then as the years gone by i got more
and more inspired and so now i'm going
to feed 50 million people personally i'm
not just from the book i'm writing a
larger check on top of it but also i'm
working with feeding america to get
matching funds to meet 100 million
people incredible so to go from my
family not being able to eat to feeding
100 million people is a pretty amazing
sense of gratitude and a sense of grace
and yeah i've done my part but there's
been grace in that as well find a role
model you know it it seems impossible
until you see somebody's done it so yeah
you know ray dalio is one of the
greatest investors in history the guy
was a caddy right you know his dad was a
jazz musician his mom was a homemaker
uh you know he's worth 14 billion
dollars
he found someone
right right you don't always find a
mentor but you find somebody you can
model and when you start seeing that
somebody else can do it and you see they
really did
you start to believe you start to get
certainty you have to say that where
your focus goes energy flows yes because
it just takes you in that right place
then the intent part sneaks in there
is the intent because you've got to pick
what you want to do or just do something
and you'll figure it out as you go you
need to be clear what it is you really
want i always tell people you know know
not only what you want but why you want
it i know this is simplistic but
most people just don't do the blocking
and tackling of their life uh the one we
were talking to earlier a great lady and
you could just see she wants to have a
new business but she never sat down to
even put a plan together and says why
aren't i taking action well when you're
not sure what you're going to do you're
going to hesitate and hesitation kills
momentum and momentum is what makes a
sports team win it's what makes an
athlete a business person win when you
get momentous like takes enormous energy
to get a rocket out of our you know our
gravitational pull of the earth but out
of the solar system is easy once it has
momentum it takes less fuel less energy
starting a relationship starting a
business changing your body it takes so
much in the beginning but once you get
going it's actually really easy money
makes you more of what you are if you if
you're mean you got more to be mean with
if you're you know giving as you are and
your team is you're gonna have more to
give with so i think it just magnifies
it doesn't change anybody but it
magnifies it and i think most of us have
so much emotion tied up around money
because we associate emotions that are
more important to us like freedom to
that or security and when you get to it
also people don't like to compare around
that area so what i try to do when i in
this latest work i did with my book
money master the game was to show people
how to master money instead of being
mastered by it because you either
mastered masters you and and trying to
pretend it doesn't matter in the world
we live doesn't make sense the real
secret is find a way to add more value
to other people than any other human
being in your industry in your category
and if you do that you won't have to
worry about money whatsoever
understanding the life cycles of
humanity there's a book called
generations it's a big book it's i think
a thousand pages eight hundred pages
but it's a book worth meaning because it
shows you how
as
every hundred years eight hundred years
we went through the same cycles like
what we've just gone through
economically in 2008 happened 80 years
before
and you can go through a thousand years
of roman history and you see it and when
you begin to be able to anticipate
what's coming
you know how to take advantage of the
season some people freeze the death in
the winter people that are prepared
might snowboard or ski and have a good
time so it's a brilliant book and it's
by strauss and how it's working the goal
if you own a business and i would assume
a lot of your viewers are business
owners or for getting started in
business
no matter how good you are in business
think about this
the one universal rule that idiots in
finance know is diversification it's the
only free lunch you've got to diversify
because if you put all your eggs in one
basket no matter how good the basket is
one day that real estate market that
stock market that bond market that
collectibles market whatever you invest
in radel you showed me statistically
it'll drop 50 to 70 on a day
now if you're later in life when that
happens it's over for you
so you have to diversify and yet most
people they know real estate so they do
it or they know stocks they do it or
they grew up with their hand their
parents flipping things and it's the
wrong thing to do so you've got to
diversify in order for you to be able to
truly succeed and that's why when you
own a business yeah if you put all your
money in your business which is what
most of us do naturally you see a lot of
risk yeah
you put all your eggs in one basket and
there's things that can happen i mean
you know you're let's say you spent 20
years and you figured out how to put
together the ultimate map you know and
you remember garmin came out with this
thing called the tomtom i don't remember
you used to put on your are you old
enough to remember that you've been
playing your phone yeah or just put on
your dash
cost a hundred bucks it was a
breakthrough
they were making like 100 million or
something or yeah yeah six months later
what happened
the iphone came out with google maps
these little bastards this is my friend
came out with it put google maps with
their own map on here and guess how much
zero what's it gonna do to your business
when someone takes your product reserve
and gives away for free so i always tell
people competition happens
technology happens what you must do is
have a second business with no with no
moving parts no people
no time maybe it takes you
two two three days a year for two or
three hours after you've read the book
you put it in place and you measure it
two three times a year that's it yeah go
on with your life now if there's a
trouble in your business you're
financially set i in my life
at 31 companies now we have you know
what we have 1200 employees
seven different industries we do five
billion in sales i mean that used to be
you know me and my seminar business it's
grown geometrically but with all those
moving parts the only way i've been able
to succeed is because i've taken every
one of those businesses and i've
diversified my assets so that when
things were in trouble
i still have enough economics to take
care of myself and keep the business
going so everybody needs to create a
money machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about if you
look at what makes people happy it's
really two things it's progress
like even you achieve your goals and
oftentimes people achieve a goal and
then they go is this all there is it's
because it didn't meet their deeper
needs our need is to keep growing you
know business is growing or it's dying a
relationship's growing or it's dying so
if you're feeling like you're not even
there but you're making progress it
feels alive because we all grow or die
and then when you make progress when you
grow you got something to give my very
first teacher was a man named jim rohn
and he was a personal development
speaker and he had this three and a half
hour seminar he would do that i went to
when i was 17 years old i was already
reading books i was obsessed with
wanting answers i want to know what made
the difference in the quality of
people's lives not because i was
intellectually interested but because i
grew up in a really tough environment i
had four different fathers there was a
lot of my mom was a great human being
who loved me dearly but she you know
abused both alcohol and prescription
drugs so she was very physically abusive
and i was believe it or not 5-1 in high
school i was a little guy so i got the
you know what beat out of me pretty
regularly for things that i didn't do
anything to do with and so it made me
try to figure out what made her work
what makes life work made me more of a
practical psychologist and the modeling
concept came because jim rohn used to
have this phrase he said success leaves
clues
he said if if there's anything you want
in your life don't assume that somebody
has some special gift they may have a
gift but they probably developed it most
of it and if you sow the same seeds
you'll reap the same rewards so figure
out what this person's doing different
than anyone else and do that he used to
have a funny way of describing he used
to say tony find out what poor people
read and don't read it
it's like because he said that's the
fabric they're trying to build their
mind from find out somebody who's
successful wealthy not just financially
wealthy but somebody who's rich
emotionally and spiritually and
physically and financially and find out
how do they live their life differently
what are the things they believe what
are they what are some of the daily
disciplines that they're a part of and
so really early on i got obsessive about
wanting to have all the answers so i
said i'm going to read a book a day
because i figured you know a person
takes 10 15 years of their life they
pour two or three four years into this
book and you absorb in a few hours
literally a decade's worth of life
experience and i'm into compressing time
so i didn't read a book a day but i read
700 books in the area of human
development psychology physiology all of
my first real seven years of reading
right my youth in high school i was mr
solution you have a problem i have a
solution especially if you're a girl i
was especially motivated i could really
help you with your boyfriend was there
something small you've done you know an
example was giving money to you know
that child was a great example of that
but is there something recently you've
done that's so small that you're like
really proud of
i you know
a lot of people don't think proud is a
good term i think it actually is
um ego is edging god out that's when you
make [ __ ] up to make yourself feel good
but i think if you've really done
something you know you have and no one
could take that from me and so i'm proud
of who i am as a man i'm proud of the
things that you know what goes on when
the camera's not on and there are people
around me all the time that will tell
the people stories about what i'm really
like so i don't have to communicate that
to people it gets shared so um i don't
know there's there's so many things in
life i don't measure them as big versus
small sure my my wife was somebody who
would see one person and be thrilled and
i had to see you know ten thousand i
think so she's balanced it out for me i
still
i feel like life is short and while
you're here i wanna have the most impact
that i can so i go deep and i go wide um
but every interaction to me is an
important interaction and and sometimes
that interaction is just being kind i
know it sounds stupid but kindness can
to the right place the right time you
know somebody can be suicidal you don't
know they're being kind and changing
their state yeah there's a interesting
story of um there's a gentleman who who
wanted to kill uh nixon
and he couldn't get access to nixon his
true story and so he became he wrote a
journal that's how we know the details
of it and he decided he's going to go
after wallace and go shoot wallace and
he actually did do that shooting
and when they read his journal it was
fascinating he didn't want to kill nixon
because he didn't like him or wallace he
just want to be famous he wanted to be
worth something
and one of the reasons he didn't kill
nixon is he was going after nixon and he
was this far from the president and old
woman bumped into him just as he's
reaching his pocket to get this gun
and in the middle of this everything's
frenzy he wants a shoe to become the
most famous man you know another one of
those assassins and this woman grabbed
his hand and said i'm so sorry i'm just
so sorry
and he said in his journal afterwards
his hand was on the gun wow and her
looking at his eyes with this love in
her eyes and this kindness in her eyes
he said i couldn't make her witness that
and he put the gun away oh man
that saved nixon's life
right soon after walls you know but
that's the power of a moment of kindness
so i think we underestimate
uh you know somebody came and fed my
family was 11 years old you know um
obviously the person must not be alive
still because i've told the story i
haven't reached out to you man reached
out to me yeah but i mean imagine what
the impact of that was by that one
little act of kindness what should i be
you know going all in on should as you
know millennials that are starting
businesses like many people in our
community uh they're you know going all
in on their business and you know
they're sacrificing profit for growth
you know so yeah they don't have that
much spare change what what's your
advice there what are your thoughts i'm
really glad you asked me that question
because every entrepreneur i meet i have
this conversation with one-on-one people
that are my friends um and i do it in my
business seminars too when i show people
i do business boot camps and i i spend
five days showing how to grow their
business 100 plus and then i take a half
a day and show them what to do to have a
second business here's what i'd say to
you if you're a founder out there if
you're somebody starting an organization
the amount of money that you get
whatever cash you have if it's a growing
business will always be eaten up by the
organization so a friend of mine ken
blanchard who wrote the one minute
manager books you may have read years
ago
i met him 30 years ago and i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game so
he thought i was god
and i don't play golf i just know what
to do here and here with somebody and so
afterwards he goes i want to do
something for you i said looks like
you're not doing anything about two
months later calls me up says i want to
have lunch with you i want to give you a
gift
he said i want to share with you the
best financial advice that changed my
life so what is it
he said this very wealthy friend of mine
saw i was writing a book
and he saw us growing my business and he
said i want to tell you something a
business he said what i told you earlier
we'll take whatever cash is there
because a growing business there's
always needs
he said you have to draw a line in the
sand and he said your book should be the
first line in the sand you should put
none of that money in your company the
clients that like the book will become
clients of the company and you shouldn't
take that money you should put an
investment account that you don't touch
and it continues to compound to create
financial freedom he said tony i took
his advice and then i went through three
different stages where he almost went
bankrupt in the business because i had
so much cash and money i wasn't stressed
so i was they'll keep my head straight
and run my business better because if
you think about and i bet i did that too
i did it with my first books now i give
away all the profits in my books my
first books and my first infomercials
yes and i work you know 275 days a year
on the road
i never earned as much as i did by
compounding because compounding changes
the game so what you have to do if
you're a business owner
you have to get yourself where you say
i'm going to put a tax on my business
not the government tax my tax my future
self is going to be free forever because
look
in business
96 of businesses don't make it in ten
years i'm sure all of yours will
but even the four percent that make it
aren't necessarily profitable
so and the reason is because government
can change the rules right taxes can
shift radically affected clients shift
their preferences technology new
competition so i tell everybody i
believe you'll make your business
succeed but everybody should have a
business on the side with no employees
no moving parts
20 minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes a year
to rebalance it so that if anything
happens here you're still strong and you
can make this stronger or if this goes
well and this goes well as well you have
twice as much money and you're there but
you got to understand what this
compounding does right this compounding
you don't need a lot of money to get
really really wealthy
you know the example of one of the
examples i put in the book here was the
example of a man who talks to a son he's
18 years old and the man understands
finance and understands the power of
compounding so he says to his son you
got your first job you're 18.
i'm going to require
that you take 300 every month 150 bucks
a paycheck and we're going to automate
it to the separate account and it sounds
like i can't do that he goes let me tell
you why you want to do it it'll be up to
you
if you promise to do that you really do
it you automate it so you don't see it
and you do that for eight years you'll
never have to invest it again and you'll
be financially set for life this thing
goes come on dad eight years three
dollars a month what is that if he does
the math he goes that's 28 000
you know over the years twenty eight
thousand eight hundred dollars twenty
eight thousand eight hundred how's that
going to do anything especially if i
don't add any more money after 27 years
old
he goes let me show you son the market's
gone up 10
over 30 years let's apply a lower number
let's do eight percent be conservative
let me show you what the numbers are
when they compound you know how much he
has when he retires 1.8 million dollars
and all he put in was 28 800. how do we
um
invest without fear
of oh it's going down i need to take it
out or like trying to time it how do we
do that great question it's one of the
main reasons i wrote the book
i always tell people if you just read
the second chapter of the book nothing
else it'll change your life you can do
that with multiple chapters but that
chapter is really about
teaching people that winter is coming we
all know winter's coming right quite a
phrase but that winter is the best time
on earth and i know that's
counterintuitive and i don't mean like
being a positive thinker i mean pure
facts so in the book i take you through
10 facts i'll give you a couple of them
right now
the first fact i get people is why do
people not invest they're afraid of
failing they if you're a millennial
right so you grew up witnessing 2008
when you're still relatively young how
old are you now 33. okay so you were
what 27 what what what 2008 um
yeah 27 yeah 27 28 years old so you're a
young man and you're watching the world
melting down in front of you for most
millennials they are the first
generation since the generation that
went through the depression that is not
investing at the ratio they need to even
close and they have more than everyone
probably right with all the they have
more college debt than everyone
absolutely true i have a friend that has
400 000 in debt dental school president
obama just paid off his debt five years
ago while he was still president no i
swear to god
it's mind-boggling and he had a bunch of
uh scholarships for the last bit it took
him that long so what i tell them is
listen
paying off your debt's not enough you've
got to become an owner or you're always
going to be in that place so yes pay off
your debt but here's what you need to
know
you got to become an owner you got to
get in the game but you got to
understand the rules of the game you
don't know the rules of the game the old
phrase is you get you know what a person
with experience meets a person with
money we know the phrase the person the
money ends up with leaks
ends up with your money right yeah so i
teach people the rules in the game so
they don't get screwed but the most
important thing is this
winter's coming
but people react so let's take last year
last january 2016 we had the worst stock
market opening in the history of the
stock market first first i think was 10
days there was a drop of 2.3 trillion
dollars with the t crazy everybody's
freaking thinking the bear market's here
the market's over the crash is here i
think the market dropped 800 points one
day and on that day all the richest
people in the world were in davos
switzerland you know for the big
conference that they do every year and
they went there msnbc went there and
everybody's freaking what's that what
are we going to do and they said let's
go ask ray dalio now your listeners may
or may not know ray value as
if
if you're not in the financial business
probably never heard of them you've
probably heard of warren buffett but ray
valley has done more you have a 5
billion net worth and 100 million
dollars to give him or he wouldn't talk
to you 10 years ago now he doesn't care
how much money you have he won't talk
because he's got a close fund but they
go and they put value on television cnbc
he's the king what do we do and he says
well you don't need to panic
corrections happen all the time yeah but
you need a strategy that when markets go
up and down you don't go up and down and
he said i spent 15 years of my life to
perfect such a strategy all of my
money's in that plan
and he said it's called all seasons and
i've never revealed it before but i gave
it to tony robbins he extracted from me
and it's his book so you got to go read
his book he says on national television
the data markets are crashing and that
day they give you an idea which is the
beginning of february i think it was
nine days in february the market was
down
9
in the first five weeks of the year
his strategy which he gave me which
is made money 85 of the time for the
last 75 years wow it's averaged the 10
return just under and the average loss
of when it fifteen percent loss was 1.6
right so if you go to vegas and you
could spend
85 percent of time make money and when
you made money was 10 your losses 1.6
you go forever his plan made two percent
while the market was down 9. so it was
up 11 difference now i'm not suggesting
that's the only strategy to do there's
many his is the smoothest ride
with the least risk but what it did was
combination of that and then right after
that i interviewed uh fed chair alan
greenspan
he was the head of our economy the the
most powerful man in finance for 19
years four presidents he was there
i was just president clinton this last
week he was he was the fed chair for him
and i interviewed him for like two hours
you know three hours off stage two hours
in front and i asked him in the very
beginning of this thing i said to him i
said look
if you
could be put in the fed today what would
you do and he looks at me and as i said
he leans forward and he says resign so i
look at that and go
oh my god i need to write a book that
will free people so here's what will
free you
everyone's afraid of the crash so here's
we need to know two terms you should
understand correction versus crash
anytime the market drops from its high
by 10 or more up to 20 it's called a
correction right if it drops 20 or more
up to 80 percent like in you know
the great depression then it's called a
crash or called a bear market okay so
how often does a correction happen
how often we have to be prepared for it
since 1900 we've had a correction on
average every year wow for 116 years so
when is winter coming this year on
average it's like how often does winter
come you wouldn't be surprised if it's
stormed in rain now some winters are
long some are short some are harsh some
are light but winter always comes so i
wasn't panicked when this happened last
year i'm not panicking whenever it
happens because i know it's supposed to
be yeah how long does it last
average
56 days okay so just under two months
what's the average drop during that time
14 over the last 30 years 13.5 of the
last 100 years so i use the more recent
one
fourteen percent get your attention
right fourteen percent you get a little
gut check
but here's you need to know eighty
percent of all corrections never become
a bear market
eighty percent
so all this fear and what people do is
what you said you did is they see it
it's freaking out and losing money i'm
the hell out of here and they get out
the stock market never took a dime from
anybody only you can take it from it you
sold that's why you lost right right so
if you look back and say what was it
like in 2008 i remember vividly
being with my platinum partners and
saying you see these 80 stocks this is
six months before the crash i told them
in april i brought them to dubai and i
said
these stocks are going to go to eight
and some are going to go to a buck
and by october and i told them what to
do so they were able to get out october
i go on the today show in october of
2008 and they go tony there's been three
trillion dollars meltdown pump the
country up you got four minutes
like ready go that's not what i do first
of all and i said i'd be alive i'm not
gonna pop up at that point the 80 stocks
rate i said some of those i said i'm not
a market forecaster but i work with paul
tudor jones one of the greatest
investors in the history of the world in
the biggest market crash in history in
1987 he made 200
wow when everybody else was losing their
entire life i've been coaching him
continuously now for 24 years every
single day so i said i work with the
best in the world and they're telling me
based on history in the 30s in history
in the 70s
this eight dollar stock summer gonna be
a buck
and i remember the day in march of 2009
citibank which had been i think 70
sold for 97 cents you could go
and take your money out of the atm yeah
it cost you more to take your money up
than to own the bank right and then i
told people it'll jump from 99 cents to
six ten twelve dollars in a month or two
is exactly what it did right so what you
got to know is corrections happen every
year you've got another couple months
god knows 14 and you won't lose because
80 times doesn't go to a bear now what
about the bear
the bear market it happens to give you
an idea in the last hundred years every
three to five years you've gone eight
without one we're way overdue yeah
in modern years last 30 years it's about
every five years
the average length of a bear is one year
the average drop is 33
a third of those drops go 40 or above
that i don't care how well prepared you
are that's a scary thing yeah
but it is the greatest opportunity in
your lifetime to go from wherever you
are financially to where you want to be
i hope your audience is listening right
now hear me
if you want a leapfrog and you're a
millennial and you think there's no
future or you're you know a baby boomer
and you think you're too old and it's
too late
the greatest gift you have is coming i
know it doesn't sound like it this is
not positive thinking [ __ ] this is
the truth
wall street
the stock market is the only place that
when things go on sale people freak out
if i said you like ferraris sure if i
said to you ferrari's going sale for 50
off awesome
but when i tell you apple's on sale for
50 off you go oh what am i going to do
here what's wrong the whole world's
coming to an end
if you think about it how old are you 33
33. so let's assume if you were 35 you
lived to 85 you got 50 52 years ahead of
you that means you have 52 more
corrections to live through right
that means you're probably in those 50
years gonna have 10 more bear markets to
live through if you're going to have a
gut checks every time or you're going to
leave out of it right if you didn't
participate because you thought oh the
market's too volatile i can't trust at
all and stuff you missed 250 percent
return in the last eight years
i mean you've missed out on everything
while you're waiting for things to be
better and if you won't do it when it's
like this when it crashes you're not
going to get in
so here's the good news about the bear
the good news about the bear average
once a year could be longer but that's
the average could be shorter but here's
what's cool every single bear market in
the history of the united states has led
to a bull market meaning right
afterwards so 2008 this plummeting what
happened in 2009 up 67
in a year i can show you every single
bear market and the next year when it
comes out it's this explosion now that's
not true in every market in the world
it's true for two centuries in the
united states so that's why warren
buffett says i want to be greedy when
people are afraid
and i want to be afraid when people are
greedy if you remember 2008 he was
telling everybody bye he was having the
time of his life bye bye bye
everything's on sale so
what you have to do to become
unshakeable
is turn when i only the metaphor i use
is the turn the snake into the rope
meaning we all know the story it's the
middle of the night you're walking
through the yard or someplace and you
see a snake and you're freaked out you
pull back you come in the morning and
it's a rope once you know it's a rope
you're never afraid again
i want to take for people investing and
show them how to turn that snake into
the rope it really is people think they
want to get rich by doing this big hit
look at all the actors
all the athletes all the movie stars
that you've seen that made more money
than god and now they're bankrupt
because they made money and income
working but they never figured out how
to make money work for them while they
slept they never made money their slaves
so if you look at like 50 cent
he made a hundred million dollars on
vitamin water someone gave him a tip
and he went bankrupt or right now i
don't know if it's really going to
happen but the newspapers are
speculating now you know johnny depp is
going through this divorce
he made three quarters of a billion
dollars 750 million dollars and they're
saying he may go bankrupt now because
he's gonna have to give up half in his
cash position and he spends 30 000 a
month on wine
and he took hunter thompson the reporter
and burned his body and paid 3 million
to blow his ashes into the atmosphere so
you can mess up now to what you do or
you can take a small amount of money and
just consistently invest it and you'll
get where you want to be financially i
met with uh david swenson he took one
billion turned into 24 billion in two
decades in 20 years
mind-boggling a billion a year right
just think about that level of doubling
it's just mind-boggling and i asked him
i said what what are the dials what are
the only dials we can touch and he said
tony to increase your return there's
only a few things you can do
he said you can make better selections
of stocks he said you can have better
timing he said and you get a better
asset allocation he said the first two
will never happen because the first two
cost you money you've got to hire
somebody everybody's wrong in the timing
he said ask the location which simply
means dividing your money into different
buckets some of those buckets are secure
so that
even though you think you're going to be
a genius you're going to make money no
matter what that money goes slower but
it'll always be there and it'll give you
freedom for the rest of your life
there's a growth bucket which is also a
risk bucket we forget that yeah because
one of things ray dalia taught me he
said tony everybody invests in what they
think they know you grew up with real
estate you're not a genius but you made
money in real estate because anybody can
when real estate's growing up yeah yeah
you think you're a genius you think you
know stocks oh you're a genius you know
in 1999 right you know you're a genius
in 2000 you know uh 10 when things
started to know that he said whatever
you invest in in your lifetime that area
is going to drop 50 to 70 percent there
is zero exception show you
mathematically and it can show you
historically so he said you have to
diversify even though you don't want to
and you have to divide these monies up
so every one of them taught me different
asset allocations but one the one that i
think is the most valuable for anybody
to to really take advantage of this ray
dalios because
ray values figured out why is it in 2008
if your
stock broker your financial planner said
we're going to protect you we're going
to put you half in stocks and half in
bonds why did they both go down
you weren't protected at all seeming up
in a 2000 and he figured something out
when you think you're in a balanced
portfolio you're not balanced and the
reason is stocks are three times more
volatile
than you'll find in bonds what does that
mean it means when you think you're 50
50 you're 50 50 with your money but
you're not 50 50 with your risk you're
95 at risk at five percent of the good
side that's why everybody loses so he
figured a formula because he said look
someday i'm going to be gone yeah i want
my kids to have the money long term i
want you know all the philanthropic
things i'm doing to be taken care of so
he spent 15 years studying the markets
and figured out
how do i design a portfolio that'll make
money
every time like if it loses money it
lost in 75 years it's lost 1.6 percent
when it's lost but it's been right 85
percent of the time wow if you went to
vegas if you were planning to work for
75 years and made money 85 of the time
and when you lost you lost 1.6 and when
you gained you gained more than 10
percent
the biggest loss in 75 years is 3.95
less than four wow so why did people not
make it in the stock market because when
you take a 50 hit they all say stay in
nobody the average person never stays in
if you look at the last 20 years the
average person the stock market over 20
years from 1993 to 2013 has averaged 9.2
percent pretty cool compounding double
your money pretty damn quick doing that
right but the average mutual fund
investors made 2.5
why
because they freak out they sell when it
goes down they buy when it's looking
good it's the wrong time to buy it they
don't know what to do so what ray
dalio's strategy does and by the way
he's never shared this strategy ever he
gives it in here he gives it in his mind
now i pushed him i teased him i
controlled him in the end i said look
you're not taking any more money help
the average guy out he lays it out you
can do it yourself or you have someone
else do it for you but it takes 15
minutes a year
and 85 percent success over 75 years and
i can take any time for your last 30
years you lost money four times one of
those was point zero zero three percent
so it's really breaking even
and again the most ever lost less than
four percent average 1.9 so if you're
looking for a plan i put some money
there and the other money that i would
do is i take some of that money and i
look at what are the biggest trends
i have a lot of my money also in senior
housing and the reason is twofold um
it's a demographic inevitability there's
this giant wave of baby boomers and
there isn't enough senior housing to
take care of them and i also i like it i
like to create a quality place for
someone to be able to be live and take
care of and so forth but there's huge
income from it and there's the growth in
the asset itself
you need to be clear what it is you
really want i always tell people you
know know not only what you want but why
you want it i know this is simplistic
but
most people just don't do the blocking
and tackling of their life uh the one we
were talking to earlier great lady you
could just see she wants to have a new
business but she never sat down to even
put a plan together and says why aren't
i taking action well when you're not
sure what you're going to do you're
going to hesitate and hesitation kills
momentum and momentum is what makes a
sports team win it's what makes an
athlete a business person win when you
get momentum it's like takes enormous
energy to get a rocket out of our you
know our gravitational pull of the earth
but out of the solar system is easy once
it has momentum it takes less fuel less
energy starting a relationship starting
a business changing your body it takes
so much in the beginning but once you
get going it's actually really easy i
don't tell people to believe spiritually
but i believe that ultimately whatever
you believe you got to live it and it
should lead to growing and giving
if you're growing you feel alive if
you're giving you feel 10 times more
life and i think if someone can
celebrate and give then that spiritual
state so to me those are the areas i
look at mastering you know business for
sure but it's the areas of life that
matter most and
most of where we spend our time doesn't
make people feel fulfilled that's why
the average person
is not fit and healthy the average
person is not in a relationship where
they have tremendous passion i'm not a
dummy i'm not a positive thinker i know
the truth the average person is not
successful in business the average
person is not earning what they want to
earn
but you know what very few people have
those things but a few do a few are
happy fulfilled spiritually alive
financially strong their business is
growing they have passionate love
affairs and i'm obsessed with finding
the few who do and find out what they do
different teaching to everybody learning
from myself and teaching everybody else
i interviewed all these nobel prize guys
as well as all these self-made
billionaires and one of them uh was a
man named [ __ ] is really brilliant he
said you know what people don't invest
because a they say i can't own the money
but you know we're all good at dieting
tomorrow you know i'm going to go to
diet tomorrow we all believe it or we're
all good at saving tomorrow we're not
going to save today because we want to
spend the money but we'll save in the
future so he said i took that pattern
and figured out a strategy and he proved
it worked in the midwest of the united
states with blue-collar workers who'd
never saved a dime he went and said i
know you say you have no money
i'd ideally like you to save at least
five percent but minimum promise me
three and a half percent because no
one's gonna miss three and a half
percent you'll adjust that easily but
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
do this plan called save more for
tomorrow we're gonna go to your employer
and you're gonna tell them whenever
you're gonna raise whatever it is next
year two years ten years doesn't matter
when
five percent whatever the first five
percent of money goes straight into this
account well within 15 years these blue
collar workers were saving an average of
15 percent and the top 40 were saving
20. when you save 20
you know i mean that's that's the
example of the guy from you know who
goes and he's got 70 million dollars he
saved 20 over time so anyone can do it
what's your definition of greatness
i don't know i think everyone has
greatness i i don't like that separation
i i respect it because in sports i think
it's really easy to measure
but sports is one aspect of life
you know i think everyone has the
opportunity great to me being a great is
being outstanding to stand out from all
the rest and and as you know in sports
it can be by you know a few microseconds
right you know the olympics you know it
could be a nose hair and you stand out
if you stand out you show the people
what's possible not everybody likes that
some people get angry and think you're
showing them up other people get
inspired i've always been inspired by
somebody who's the best in the world at
what they do and so i think greatness is
somebody who just will not settle and
finds a way to do be share and create in
life what they want as opposed to
fitting in i think most people are
trying to
not be rejected you know i wrote in this
book you know i took a a quote from
an aristotle saying you know how do you
really live your life well if you don't
upset anybody it's really simple don't
do anything don't say anything don't be
anything and everybody will like you you
know
but if you want to have a quality life i
think you just have to put yourself on
the line and so to me greatness is
people that put themselves on the line
they keep growing and they won't settle
we live in a culture where most people
are dabblers today because
today it it if you ask me what does it
take to be happy and give it to one word
progress progress equals happiness when
you're making progress in your body even
if you're not there yet you feel good
you achieve your goal and you just sit
around you're not happy we gotta grow we
gotta make progress
it's easy to make progress in the
beginning of something in the beginning
of a relationship who doesn't have a
good time right in the beginning of
starting a business if you love what
you're doing of course you're gonna have
a great time in the beginning ending
it's easy a job it's fun in the
beginning it's novelty it's new
mastery
is when you've worked in the beginning
of learning a sport how fast do you
learn tennis i mean just like zooms up
here you didn't know anything you
thought love you know was an emotion you
find out it's a score you know
you go like this but then you hit this
plateau
and most people in that plateau they go
wrong job right wrong relationship wrong
business because it's not instantly
fulfilling them but the people that go
i'm going to fight through and go deep
i'm going to find a way to break through
i'm going to find a way to learn and
know more about this in a human life so
that i can help as many human beings as
possible and it won't be [ __ ]
because i've lived it there is a power
in mastery and how many people do you
know are really committed to mastery
today most people dabble in a million
things they master nothing and they
wonder why they're unfulfilled because
they're running for the sugar the next
thing that feels good instead of getting
past what doesn't feel good and getting
to where you own something i went
through a divorce i decided i i met a
woman fell in love with her and fell in
love with her kids she'd been married
twice before me she was 12 years my
senior so i was 24 and had a 17 year old
son instantly an 11 year old a
five-year-old and one on the way
really great lady but we're completely
different no one tells you how to pick
your partner but i fell in love with the
children so i was like
i i don't want to lose these kids you
know so i eventually decided to get a
divorce when i got the divorce it was a
not happy divorce from the standpoint if
i try to give her half of everything but
they got it 10 times most yeah eight
times and a ten times multiple in all my
companies in those days i didn't have 31
i had like seven
and they were small companies they
weren't billion dollar companies they
were like less than 100 million most of
them yeah and some of them were only
dependent upon me like like a doctor if
i don't show up the whole thing falls
apart
and so i'm looking at this
i got to pay her eight and ten times i
got to pay for 50 million dollars and i
didn't have 50 million dollars so i
settled on 42 million i had a pair of 42
million when i didn't have it and i
started over at 39 years old
and
i had to pay her not only 42 million but
i paid a million dollars a year for 17
years i was only married to her for 14
years right wow so i just paid that off
a couple years ago
and the reason i tell you the story is
in the beginning i had to pay a million
dollars a year
plus i had to pay the taxes on it before
i ate
it was and when i met her she was broke
now i was broke and that was the best
the world was doing but the power of
that was
when i wouldn't let go when i finally
said i'm gonna stop being angry i'm just
gonna automate it let go my capacity
grew 10-fold it's like i never looked
back it was like because i had to come
up with an additional million dollars i
had to think bigger i had to do things
bigger so i started creating new
relationships new partnerships new
businesses and it made me grow to a 5
billion a year company set of companies
versus not even a little more than 100
million back in those days so in eight
years my life has transformed because i
i put that tax on myself and i invested
heavily and i didn't have the money to
do it but i did it anyway because i had
to and the second thing i tell people is
feeding your mind is great but you've
got to also strengthen your body and you
do that as an athlete naturally i
learned to do that because fear is
physical right you know where you feel
it and if you go work out if you go lift
if you go run even if you're out of
shape you just go from an intense walk
that experience alone changes your life
every day in my life the first thing i
do before i do my priming
if i'm one of my homes i jump in some
hot water for fun and i jump in freezing
water and i have you know a river you
know and one of my homes in sun valley
and i've got cold punches everywhere so
i go in 57 degree water boom and what it
does is like it's teaching my brain i do
i tell my brain what to do and it does
it it doesn't feel like it doesn't want
to do it and every cell in your body is
alive right so it doesn't have to be
like two hours worth of something it
could be something you do for 30 seconds
but it's training your body to be strong
because a strong body could strong mind
and vice versa we all have a need for
certainty we have a need to know we can
avoid pain that we can be comfortable
some people do that when they're
stressed by smoking some people work out
hard to deal with some people eat to try
to get that comfort back but if you were
certain every moment of your life you
know what people are going to do when
they're going to do it how they're going
to do it you'll be bored out of your
mind so we also need uncertainty if you
have too much uncertainty you forgot if
you have too little you feel bored out
of your mind and you can get uncertainty
or variety by a great conversation by
making love by taking on a new job or a
new career a new opportunity you get a
million ways the question is do you meet
your needs in ways that are positive or
negative because sugar will make you
feel good in the moment but you feel
good long term smoking a cigarette will
make you comfortable and certain
but it might be variety it changes how
you feel when you're stressed so it
meets two needs that's why it's not
sustainable that's what makes somebody
addicted the most important thing first
is if you're going to succeed in
business you have to know who your ideal
client is who is the client that is your
ideal that if you built your business on
that it would grow if the economics of
the economy dropped they'd still buy
from you that's the person you want to
cherish you want to fall in love with
you don't fall in love with your product
you want to fall in love with your
client and you want to know more about
them than anybody else because i always
say life is the dance between what you
desire most and what you fear most so if
you can expand your desires and break
through your fears you expand your life
massively so for the people that are
really watching i think the more you
know about those needs if you can do
more for them than anybody else then you
go to the second piece which is add more
value than anyone in your industry if
you do more for others than anybody else
and you don't just do it for a day or a
week or a month you do it like i always
tell people most people overestimate
what they're going to do in a year but
they underestimate what they can do in a
decade or two or three if you do that
year after year
the word spreads and you start to build
a brand and if you do that for a decade
or more you can start to actually
dominate the industry so you got to know
everything about them you got to add the
value and you got to find an
irresistible offer
tom shoes irresistible offer he took a
product quite frankly product's not very
good at all
but the offer is really great if i buy
and wear these crappy shoes you'll get
another pair and you'll give them
someone who doesn't have shoes i'm in
and now a bunch of people mop they're
doing it with glasses and things of that
nature or 99 cents on itunes i mean
people are getting everything for free
why should i buy it
better fidelity easy clear but only 99
cents that offer zappos
right tony shea is a good friend of mine
he comes up and he joins the founders
and they're living in this little house
in san francisco and they're totally
frustrated we're spending all this money
and we're trying to sell women's shoes
online and it's not working how come
well they got to try them on and well
they aren't doing it because they don't
want to spend the money on shipping it
and tony shea changes the offer he says
look
we're going to let people
order as many shoes as they want we're
going to pay for all the shipping and if
they don't like anything send them back
we pay the shipping back now if you're
the investor in the company what do you
say are you crazy we're going to go
bankrupt because you don't understand
our ideal customer these women they have
a different relationship to shoes than
you and i do women say shoes equal
happiness a woman can put on one shoe
she's one woman she changes shoes she's
another woman right and he said they're
gonna get these shoes and we're gonna
pay if you get them there they're not to
send them back 99 of the time because if
they like the shoe even if it doesn't
fit they'll convince themselves it'll
fit in the future right and when i talk
about this in like big seminars women
are laughing raising their hand going
yeah high five and it's true and he
built a business he sold for 1.2 billion
dollars and he still runs it because he
wasn't doing it for the money he loved
building the culture and doing this but
he came up with that irresistible offer
so know more about them make sure you
add value massively have an irresistible
offer be three things i'd start with if
i gave you a fourth one thrown in you
better know your numbers right i do
these boot camps and i bring in a guy
that's just a genius who gives them like
an nba in five hours it sounds like an
exaggeration but it's not he's done
billions of dollars of the deals and he
teaches them how to know the numbers
because most entrepreneurs that's not
their skill
they're good at marketing or creating a
product or innovating or selling or
whatever
but the financials is why most people
die because
you don't want an accountant you need a
cfo
and yet when you're a small company you
can't afford to see a focus they're like
you know four hundred thousand dollars
what's different about a cfo than
account it kind of just puts the numbers
in the right columns he'll tell you all
you have this much profit you go yay and
then you find out at the end of the year
there was no cash
profit and cash are not the same thing
oh my god what am i going to do so
understanding your numbers and
understanding that profit is a theory
right you got a big profit and no cash
you have to understand how that works
and you got to just take the time to get
that skill so that numbers become
intelligence because if you have the
right numbers and you know what they
mean
now you can make better decisions you
make better decisions you're going to
win in the psychological realm um
everyone's going to measure themselves
differently because everyone values
things differently some people value
success or significance some people
value love more some value just
basic levels of certainty
so when i look at the specific metrics i
really look at
metrics of what are the things that need
to be measured to know if your life is
going to work or not so i look at it as
our whole lives are guided moment to
moment by the state we're in learning
how to change your state
not [ __ ] not fake but to go from
pissed off frustrated freaked out to
back in your center or creative or
determined or something that's going to
move you forward it's going to create a
better quality of life for you and
others that's a critical skill set the
most powerful decision we make most of
us don't make it consciously is what are
we going to focus on we don't focus on
everything we focus on a small number of
things and that's what we experience in
life
because you could be focusing right now
on the blood rushing through your left
ear or the touch of your clothes against
your skin but you don't
most of what your brain does is distort
delete and generalize it makes life
simple
and the problem is you distort delete
and generalize you miss a lot of your
life
and focus right down equals feeling
whatever you focus on you're going to
feel even if it's not true if i asked
you there are two things you could focus
on what you have or what's missing which
one do you spend more time focusing on
if your brain is constantly focusing
what's missing how can you ever sustain
happiness no matter how successful you
become it is impossible
what happens when you focus on what you
have
you feel alive you feel no scarcity you
feel joy how many of you have lots of
things in your life that if you focused
on it you could feel grateful for you
could feel excited about how many got
lots of things like this now say i
but it doesn't exist unless you focus on
it and we all have patterns of focus
do you tend to focus more on what you
can control or what you can't control
what's outside your control what is
someone gonna feel is constantly focused
on what's missing and what they can't
control sad frustrated angry depressed
so why are they still depressed because
they are still focusing on what's
missing
and they're focused on what they can't
control and i'll add one more do you
tend to focus more on things from the
past the present or the future we all do
all three but if you're going to spend
your predominant time and you want
enjoyment it's the present if you want
to be create a great life it's the
future so it's a balance between the
present and future people say what does
it take to be happy i say one word
progress
if you're not there yet but you are
starting to make some progress on your
body of progress on your relationship
with progress on your career your
finances you're going to feel good and
when you achieve it how long do you feel
good for not very long because when you
achieve it you stop growing you kind of
celebrate nothing wrong with that but
how long after you get that thing you
wanted are you happy a week a month a
year almost never a year it's a short
time and the reason is we're not
supposed to just sit there at the table
of success and celebrate for years
we need to grow to feel alive and
everything in the universe grows or dies
but when we grow we have something to
give and when we give that's people
often say human beings are selfish i've
been selfish i'm sure you've been at
times but that's not my core and it's
not anybody's and i'll prove it to you
when you're having all of you at home
and all of you here when you have
something great in your life that
happens you learn something you
experience something beautiful what's
the first thing you want to do tell
people share somebody what you love why
because when you share with it it
expands see pleasure is something coming
in from the outside happiness is
something inside you that you share
and if you happiness is what people
really want pleasure you get pleasure
from alcohol or sex or anything but some
people there it's all about me when
you're taking what's inside yourself
because you've grown and you're giving
to someone you love your children a
friend a girlfriend boyfriend a
co-worker anybody there's an aliveness
you can't feel by yourself there's only
so much pleasure you can feel happiness
and joy comes when that expansion is
shared in the early stages of me on
myself as an entrepreneur i started all
these companies from scratch
and then i met a gentleman the gentleman
started mtv
and we had this really cool conversation
he said you know tony it took me
you know a decade and a half to really
build up mtv and he said and then i
built another company and he said tony
you know i realized
it takes like seven years that was his
number in his head on average to go from
scratch to build something that's really
stable and strong and so forth you know
he goes i realize there's only so many
seven year cycles in my body
and he said but if i went to a company
that already has been around for seven
10 20 years and i bring my ability my
vision my ability to grow that business
my ability to inspire the people my
ability to produce resourcefulness
then i get a multiplied effect and he
goes tony you're the best in the world
at what you do
but damn you work your tail off and so
he asked me if i'd come speak he one of
the companies he took over with century
21 real estate
and he said why haven't you ever spoken
for us because your company asked me
over and over but they're cheap you know
they want to pay me a hundred thousand
dollars my fee is a quarter of a million
he goes oh he goes we'll pay the
quarterback i said no for you i'll do it
for free because he's a friend and i'm
learning from him so i came into the
speech and afterwards he sat me back
down he goes tony
there are ten thousand people here he
says i know like all my financial guys
they all looked you but you're like a
rock star from middle america these
people in gold jackets selling real
estate he goes do you know how much our
business increased in those four months
and i remember the exact number was like
22 or 23 or something goes too much
money you made me and you got nothing
he said let me give you some advice
go find people that have some form of
momentum that you can turn it around
and get a piece of that and that's how i
change so what i looked for were
businesses that i felt tremendous
emotional connection to because i
thought they'd touch people's lives in
some way and i looked for partners that
were geniuses but where i could bring my
own genius to it where one plus one
equals five or at least three not two
and by doing that i got pieces of these
different companies and then it just
grew and grew and grew and grew so i'm
in virtual reality a company called
nexvr my partners are geniuses and we
just lock down the exclusive for the nba
so instead of monday night football we
have tuesday night nba and you literally
it's like you're on the court you can
look and it feels like you can reach out
and touch lebron it's mind-boggling and
there's no chords or computer it's all
done off your phone with an app it's
mind-boggling um we also have the
exclusive for live nation for all
concerts so you can be right there next
to jay-z or beyonce like you feel like
you can touch them right i've
accompanied us
number one guy in stem cells in the
world i have a company that does
genetics you know that's just genius um
i've got companies that are in the
education space i bought adweek with a
group of partners i have my financial
companies so the diversity i have is
mind-boggling but that's also the secret
to investing
you know if you got all your eggs in one
basket there's a problem you need to
make sure you run your business really
successful give it your all not start 20
of them but once that business really is
strong and your investments are strong
then you can build a second one most
people they build a business and then
it's not going as well as they want so i
start another business because it feels
more exciting and it's like you have one
child you're not taking care of so let's
have a second child and a third child
and it just doesn't work but the
diversity of it also makes me excited so
i manage 12 of them actively the others
i have such great partners like you know
i own
uh you know the major league soccer new
franchise in la i'm a partner in that uh
it's called the la football club but my
partner's peter guber owns the la
dodgers and owns the golden state
warriors and about as smart a human as
you could ever have in the sports field
and then i bought
in the esports field you know it's
mind-boggling people we fill whole
stadiums now people watching people play
video games so i bought team liquid
which with my partners with peter and
everyone else and and so i mean the
opportunities are just amazing because
i'm partnering with people who have
skills that are the best in the world
and i'm bringing mine and when you
combine them you know you get a greater
impact everyone has different goals and
dreams and desires but as i travel
around the world to 100 countries i
started going holy [ __ ] i'm seeing the
same problems what's underneath it i
began to see that there are these same
six human needs that we all have the
same needs we all have a need for
certainty that we can avoid pain and we
can have some pleasure some comfort we
all need uncertainty we need variety or
we feel dead inside if you're totally
certain you're bored if you have total
variety you're like freak out and it's
not a balance it's learning which of
these you need more as a person
everyone's developed a different set of
values in that area um need the need for
significance to feel unique special
important they need to feel loved the
need to grow and the need to contribute
some people value certainty at the top
of their list that's their center of
their target i don't want to do anything
else i know it's going to work i don't
do anything unless it's the same if you
change anything they freak out
if certainty is the number one thing on
your list everyone has the same needs
but if it's number one i know how your
life's gonna be i can predict the
direction of your life and therefore the
destination to some extent
if you're driven by love first you want
certainty too but love is higher you're
gonna behave very differently than if
you're driven by significance i have to
be the one
your experience in business was
trying to be significant by making
enough money and being successful enough
that you would feel what you really want
which is that feeling of love what you
call uh
not what would you call lottery
camaraderie thank you camaraderie so
that feeling of it's really love it's
it's the friendship it's the camaraderie
it's that component that's what really
drives you and so you figure out how to
organize your life where that's the
driving force and now look what you've
done you flourished and everyone around
you is flourishing so i look to see
which of those needs are the top two on
your list because they control your life
the two that most people have ninety
percent of the planet if you said of all
these
needs
which one do you really focus on most
day to day everybody wants love what do
you focus on most people focus on being
significant we live in a facebook world
where people fake their life put new
filters make it look different than it
really is tell stories that you know are
totally full of it to make himself look
good because we live in this kind of
false world where significance is more
important than love right and it
separates us and the other one that we
see most often is certainty people want
to be certain before they can do
something you couldn't have started a
business like you had if you were
absolutely certain before you started
you can never build a business with that
you can never build a great relationship
because if it's based on certainty then
everybody's got to stay the same never
change which means you're never going to
grow which means you're going to be
miserable right so my metrics are i want
to find out what's driving you
i want to see is it healthy or unhealthy
you can have two people be driven by
significance though and do it with a
different
set of rules that's the second piece i
measure the beliefs or rules of how to
fulfill that target
so
osama bin laden
certainty driven
love driven contribution dipping
significance driven not hard to figure
out
on a 0-10 he was a 10 for significance
he was the whatever i'm making the
number but he was like the 27th child of
his father 22nd child most people know
that totally insignificant not skilled
took his dad's money went over to
afghanistan and suddenly because he had
money he became significant and he
started he wasn't even part of that
movement at that stage it shaped him so
what does he do he's going to figure out
his model of the world is i'm
significant if i destroy you
right
on that same day of 9 11 there were men
and women in the fire
police department they were also driven
by significance and contribution
and they went into the building knowing
they're likely going to die to save a
stranger
both people driven have a significant
life one is by taking life one is by
giving their own life
so
once you understand the metrics using
your language of what's driving you and
then the rules or beliefs that what does
it take for you to feel loved it's
different for everybody what does it
take for you to feel certain some people
need a billion dollars some people just
need to trust god connection right
versus significance i want to be the
best
so i got to be different but i want to
be in community with you i want to be
close to you i want i want love and i
want connection but see what most people
like you see this and and great actors
or great uh entertainers they'll come to
me and in the beginning they worked so
hard to be significant to be unique to
be special to be important what they
really wanted was love but now people
stop on the street and they'll say to me
they don't even know who i am they just
want my time they just want this they
want a picture they don't respect my
family they don't respect it you'll hear
them so upset what they wanted was the
love but see
we we can have both but the more
significant i am the more unique i am
the more separate i am from you the more
connected i am then some people go yeah
but where am i where am i special
so the finding that balance between the
two is what makes people feel alive and
we can meet all these needs in positive
ways or negative ways you get
significance by tearing other people
down oh they don't they're lucky they
they don't care they took advantage of
somebody you know anything about them
you see people dealt with famous people
all the time why are they tearing them
down because if i don't feel good about
myself if i can make you smaller i look
like i'm moving up but you're not and it
doesn't work but if you do things where
you significantly love someone if you
care for someone you're the most
significant person in life if you try to
prove you're significant then you have
kind of the trump effect even people
like him will say you know sometimes he
can push people aside because he's
telling everybody how special he is i'm
not making a political statement i'm
saying that gets in the way of
relationship if we're going to connect
we got to not make ourselves significant
we've got to find out what's significant
in the other person and honoring when i
was
32 33
maybe 34 somewhere in that range i was
really frustrated because i love what i
do for a living it's emotional rewards
are gigantic but it's not a it's not a
business that has a great deal of you
know opportunity for maximizing profit
because this is a low margin business
and i didn't get into it's like what's
the best business get in is this i'm an
artist i want to help people change
their lives this is my this is my
mission
so
you know we were in the 9 10 margin and
it doesn't take much of a challenge when
your margins that small to have a real
challenge in your business so i called a
group of billionaire friends of mine
that i've coached over the years and i
always want to be the giver i never
asked for anything but i said to them
look i have these
seven or eight opportunities that are
being put in front of me that look
incredible i still want to run my core
business but i'd love to get your
coaching i've coached you guys would you
be willing to coach me just for a couple
hours so i brought them all here in new
york had this incredible meeting i'll
never forget
and i decided i wanted to add value so i
introduced them to each other they all
knew of each other they're all kings of
the titans of business some some were
friends and then i said so let me show
you the good the bad the ugly of my
story and so i told them my
entrepreneurial story from the very
beginning no money the ups and downs the
near-death experiences
and i was watching their eyes get this
big because a lot of them they didn't
start businesses like that right some
started businesses by getting a billion
dollar loan one guy right he was able to
do because it's financial backing
and so i can see them getting more and
more intense and long story short at the
end they're like
stop stop stop you shouldn't do any of
these opportunities they're all
wonderful opportunities you got to go
back and maximize your business you have
to maximize your business and one of the
guys had just been to one of my seminars
when i unleashed the power within
seminar and he told me came up to me
tony's the most incredible thing i've
ever done in my life because tony you
work so hard you're on stage 12 14 hours
a day i don't know how you hold people's
attention people won't sit for a
two-hour movie three-hour movie and you
got people so you're never going to want
to do this when you're like 42. you know
because i was like 32. same guy three
weeks later goes you're not working hard
enough on your business i'm like what
the hell right and what it was was they
all reacted because they're used to a
different type of business
and
one of the guys afterwards says hey i
was near tears because i walked in
thinking on the greatest business
opportunities in the world and i walked
back feeling like i'm a piece of you
know what right and one of the guys the
billionaire says to me he goes hey tony
where are you staying i'm at the four
seasons he goes i'm staying there too
three blocks away can i walk with you i
want to get your advice on something i
thought who me dumb f i'm the one you
want this advice from right and he says
to me i'll never forget he goes
tony you know in front of the
underwear company he goes up i got an
offer
they make me a about a billion nine
so i kind of i gotta decide do i do i
sell the company
do i build it up bigger and then sell it
or do i keep it for my son
and i said i said bill i said i love you
to death i said you already know the
answer you just you want me to confirm
it for you let's be honest i said first
of all if you sell the company now get a
billion eight billion nine more it's not
going to change your life one iota you
have the planes the cars the homes the
all that stuff plenty of cash i'm not
going to change you but if you sell when
the business is not at its peak you'll
resent yourself later on you'll you'll
be mad because you're a guy that loves
to maximize he goes oh you're so right
and i said keeping it for your son he's
five right does he want to be the
underwear king i don't think so i said
go build it a little bit more to the
level you know it is and then sell it
right and he goes oh my god it's so
brilliant so great but what i got on
this conversation that changed my life
was i hated it i felt they didn't
understand and they didn't understand a
bunch but i said there's got to be some
truth in there and then i saw this uh
story about this guy
who spent i think it was 17 years
looking for the spanish galleon his name
was mel i'm playing a last name but it
was very famous in the 1990s 80s
and
he literally
made no money found nothing like 16
years into it he had to convince people
to give him more money one of his
members his crew died it was the most
brutal approach how could you possibly
keep going out there
looking for treasure
and not finding it for five years not
giving up or 10 16. i think he went 18
if i remember correctly and
he found a half a billion dollars with
the gold so i asked myself a question
i said
what would make a guy
go 16 17 18 years with no evidence of
success and keep doing and convince
people to give him money and keep going
working seven day weeks he'd have to
believe something different than other
people what would he have to believe i
thought first he'd have to believe the
treasure's there
i didn't believe the treasure was in my
business
so you didn't find it right
second you'd have to believe i will find
it
and third to go that many years you'd
have to believe it's worth it
and i shifted those three beliefs in my
business
and i cr things i once i committed
completely to that business and nothing
else
i grew the business like crazy and i end
up selling half that business for 200
million dollars the business that looked
like it would never make anything
when i did that i said now i'm a
successful entrepreneur now i'll take on
some other companies because i'm not
bs'ing myself i've really built it this
idea you're gonna go build nine
companies nice ego stroke no way you can
give them the focus that you need but
today i can do more with my pinky than i
used to be able to work in 20 hour days
because i know more people i have more
contacts i have more strategy i have
more tools and so you've got to make
sure you maximize something and really
make a real business you want to know
your real test could you sell the
business tomorrow for a significant
multiple if not don't start another
business or get rid of his business sell
it and start something fresh but most
people are always looking for what's
easier and it always looks easier what
you really want to do is maximize the
business you're in if you want to break
through not just a little change you
know you can change laterally you know
you can go from being pissed off to
frustrated
right doesn't help much right but if you
really want to change most people are
trying to change so you want to lose
weight they want to make money they go
how do i do it they look for the
strategy but i like all three of you to
think of three s's strategies where most
people go first like how do i do it but
how hard is it really truly to be fit
and have energy it's not that complex
it's not like reserved for the one
percent or expensive to learn you have
to interrupt you have to hide from the
answers to those things the real problem
is the second s story see the reason the
person is making progress they may not
know what to do sometimes that's true
but some don't know what to do and they
don't do what they know that's most
people yes and so why they have a story
that says it's a set of beliefs they
tell themselves over and again i've
tried everything or if they're single
all the good ones are gone you know you
know whatever the story is and if you
tell yourself a story over and over
again you know hitler used to say tell a
story big enough loud enough long enough
people believe you well we're hitler to
ourselves we convince ourselves the
thing we really need that was
you always come up with a lousy story
when you're in a lousy state yeah and so
the number one thing i show people do is
how to change their emotional state when
you're feeling tired or frustrated when
you learn how to change your body so
that you really feel excited and isn't
fake when you learn how to change your
biochemistry which is what i teach
people to do when for example when
you're in love when you when you're
upset with someone do you ever notice
how you can now remember everything that
they've ever done that ever upset you
and when you're in love when you're
telling life everybody make the sound of
being in love try it
oh it's been a while for some of you
clearly let's try it again out of your
mind and love you can't stop thinking
about the person make the sound how that
feels go for it everybody
[Applause]
i will work on that
but when you're in love what's wrong
with life
what's wrong with anything when you're
loving oh we have no money who cares
we're in love right
so your emotional state controls the
story you have about your life and then
your story determines whether you find a
strategy or even if you know the
strategy whether you really do it or not
when people say i tried what they're
really telling me is i have a story that
says i should try this but it's really
not going to work so i give it a half
weird attempt and it didn't work and i
can tell people i tried what you really
got to do is learn to change your
emotion your state change your story and
then you can find the strategy or you
can make the strategy to work so what do
you want do you want a thumb wrestle i
want to see you do your move if
have you ever done this before no go for
it okay
you got to get my thumb down
you got to hold it for three seconds
okay
you got big hands
okay that's going to go on for 20
minutes
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
when you watch a video and just get
motivated you have a 35 chance of
actually following through that's what
the science says and that is not good
enough believe nation we need to do
better when you actually get motivated
and then create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do this
week you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you publicly commit to
somebody else like leaving a comment
below in this video it jumps even higher
so i want that for you i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week so i can celebrate with you
by the way when you love conditionally
who always gets hurt
you do because we do because when you
love conditionally it feels like a trade
i i love you as long as and the person
knows that at some level and so they
can't really love back because it isn't
love it's manipulation i'll be nice to
you if you give me this i'll love you as
long as you behave the way i want as
long as you speak the way i want you to
speak as long as you agree with the
league as long as you follow my rules
the blue rules
that make me comfortable then i'll love
you
but that's not love
that's you just finding a way to meet
your own needs for certainty and
significance
there's nothing wrong with that it just
leaves you empty
and creates lots of pain how many see
so the only way out of pain
is more spiritual growth and as
simplistic as that sounds or over
generalized
spiritual growth just means seeing more
of life than just your self
right what is this increase
in consciousness i hate the term because
it's so overused by people a lot of
people use it to i'm so conscious that's
significance talking but consciousness
is caring
when you're egocentric all you care
about is
yourself and we're all egocentric if
we're getting enough fear
enough survival
and kids are all egocentric people say
kids are so loving bull they're loving
when you give what they want otherwise
they scream their ass off but we love
them because we're drugged
drugged by natural guts oxytocin it's
our child we love them no matter what
it's a beautiful thing otherwise kids
wouldn't survive
because they're selfish [ __ ]
we don't see it thank god
but we need to grow by the way why when
you're a child you get love for no
matter what you do you get loved until
oxytocin wears off and then all of a
sudden the rest of your life you got to
earn it
because if life always just gave you
what you wanted all the time you'd never
grow spiritually it would all be me me
me me
and yet we've all been loved so deeply
because we know it's there but we're
supposed to know it's there not to go
get it so we go get it out of ourselves
and give it people ask my wife all the
time what's something about tony that
nobody knows and she says the level he
prepares so that was ray dalio i know i
got a chance to be with literally the da
vinci of investing most average people
never heard his name but right
you have to have a ten years ago jeff a
five billion dollar net worth and he had
to give him a hundred million to start
with for him to talk to you right today
he won't talk to you and take your money
how much money you have he's he's closed
his fund out he won't he won't do a dime
more so to do that
i i couldn't i couldn't consciously walk
in and just say okay i've read
everything it's available i had to watch
every video there's only a few out there
i had to read every piece i had to like
tear it apart and see if i could
understand his entire structure of
investing so that when i was there i
could ask questions no one else was
asked before and as a result he actually
shared with me he's averaged a 23 return
for 21 straight years
billions and billions and billions of
dollars smartest man one of the smartest
man alive in that area and because i
understood so much we could pitch and
catch you know most people you know you
can just they just they can just throw
the ball right but i need i want to
throw the ball and have you throw it to
me and throw it right back to you right
that's where we get something that's
really exciting and because i prepared
at that level he was saying to me after
he goes you know this better than
anybody i know and he's so it opened him
up more and you talked to me in more
detail in the end he actually gave me a
strategy
that i said to him i said look i said
ray
i said you're one of the most generous
men i know
i said you've just given me this
incredible strategy but the strategy was
like explaining why most people lose
money and here's how he's made money in
every market right pretty complex
strategy and i said the strategy is
great but it's kind of like you told me
you want to build a chocolate cake get
some chocolate you know get some sugar
you can tell me the amounts i mean the
amounts are everything right get over
the right amounts and he goes tony i
can't give you that that's my secret
sauce
and i said ray you can give it to me
because i can't he goes that's my that's
what i get you know that's why you know
i get the money i do i said no you don't
you haven't taken money for 10 years
i said you're going to give away half
your net worth anyway i said you just
got done telling me the average guy is
never going to do this help me out give
me your secret sauce right and i got him
laughing he goes well tony it's kind of
complex i said i'm going to take complex
and making it simple he goes well i use
leverage i said create one without
leverage so the average guy could do it
right and then i got this chilled on the
back of my spine when he said well it
wouldn't be perfect i said your idea not
perfect it's not better than anybody
else on earth i said right tell me and
then i took out a pen and just said tell
me the numbers right he looked at me
goes
well let's try this and he starts to lay
this thing out so when i'm done i can
feel the vibration in my body like i got
something nobody's got that i can give
to the world that'll be extraordinary
and i go he goes go test that he goes
don't when people talk about testing
they look back five years or ten years
he said
but the past doesn't equal the future
that way but if you were to test
something over 75 years the entire
modern time of history that's what you
should test that formula back test it
for 75 years come back tell me what you
get
85 of the time it's for 75 years think
of how much the world has changed the
last 10 years or 20 years 85 percent of
the time it makes money
the 15 percent of the time it didn't
the maximum drawdown in 75 years was not
20 like you've seen at 30 or 40 you've
seen in the marketplace over the years
3.9 percent the average loss is 1.7
average gain is 10 so if you could go to
vegas and you could be right 85 of the
time and when you lost only lose you
know one percent 1.7 percent how you'd
be you'd be investing a little bit you'd
be gambling a little bit right so he
gave it to me so i got those types of
things because i was so prepared and so
when i go to do an audience a big
audience like i do my date with sd
seminar people do 20 pages of homework
and i read all that for a couple
thousand people i won't remember their
faces i don't remember it's in my brains
once somebody stands up something inside
me recognizes the pattern or recognizing
this the pattern that multiple people in
the room need to deal with and my brain
clicks in and makes it happen so i
believe
you know garbage and garbage out as
simplistic as it is that if you keep
putting unbelievable quality amount in
when it's time for you to cash that
spiritual emotional
physical financial business check it
ain't going to bounce because you've
been making deposits and you have plenty
to give you're not you're not just
winging it to see what happens so i'm
intense about that but i also love it
because it just i'm always growing too
because i'm always learning more than i
need to teach anybody else extraordinary
life is life on your terms
and there's two parts
part one to have an extraordinary life
is mastering the skill
of the science of achievement
how do i take what i envision and make
it real and how do i do that quicker
faster better easier the ability to
manifest what you come up with and make
it real like you've done with your
company yes that's a skill set i spend
unbelievable amount of time helping
people do it faster quicker better
showing the shortcuts teaching in the
strategies modeling what works you can
save yourself a decade
but
i would submit to you that having done
this for 38 years
with you know 50 million people at this
stage
i can tell you that the science of
achievement there are a lot of people
that are damn good at that
and they still don't have an
extraordinary life they have an
extraordinary life you see it as
extraordinary but i get the phone call
from the multi-billionaire right who
tells me he wants to do this thing on
his business but what he really find out
is he's miserable as hell and he's
hoping somehow i'm going to rub off on
him on that side too and so i give him
what he asks for the change in his
business but i also get what he needs
which is the change inside of him
so the second skill
is the art of fulfillment if you want
extraordinary life you can't just
achieve you got to be fulfilled as
simplistic as that sounds but it's an
art
it's not a science
it's a science to making money come on
any age any color any background any
gender if you do these things you'll
have an abundance of money you do these
things you're going to have too much
month at the end of the month you're
going to financial stress right
body everyone's biochemically different
but you and i both know there's
fundamental rules laws there's a science
in the body you violate that science
you're going to have disease you're
going to have low energy you align with
that you're going to have an abundance
of energy it's going to affect
everything in your life it's a science
fulfillment's not like that
fulfillment is as different as our human
beings you want to know what god or the
universe likes look at the jungle look
at the forest it's diverse right
so
most people
think well i want to get that because
they've been modeling somebody else and
that might work on how to achieve
something it'll never work for what a
fulfill you how many people you know
like you got what you thought you wanted
and you weren't fulfilled and that i
always tell people success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure the
ultimate failure because if you go at
something and you fail and you're an
achiever you don't fail you go i learn
something i'll just try something else
i'm gonna still get there but when you
succeed and you're not happy
you're technically screwed and just like
what are you going to do so
a perfect example this i mentioned in
the seminar you were there because it
hit me about what about a year and a
month ago we lost what i consider a
national treasure robin williams
and i asked people how many love robin
williams everybody racing all around the
world right he made people laugh people
were touched by him
so how good was he at the science of
achievement
i mean he wanted to be a great comedian
make the whole world laugh he did he
wanted to have his own tv show he didn't
want the number one show he did it he
wanted to make movies he did he wanted
to have an academy award for not being
funny dramatic and he did it right he
did it yeah he said he wanted a
beautiful family he achieved everything
and he hung himself that's crazy and i
know recently someone's saying well you
know he had dementia he had drug abuse
he had alcohol abuse the most his life
because he made everybody happy but whom
himself
that's the ultimate failure so if i had
no other message to offer your viewers
and you let me give it to them right now
i'll tell you what i believe
i believe our lives are controlled by
one force decisions
i certainly believe in force greater
than myself call it god if you will
grace whatever you want to call it the
universe
but i also believe it gives us choices
and the decisions we make control us
much more than the conditions we meet
it's not the conditions it's your
decisions decisions what to believe
decisions what to do decisions what to
give i say to people think about
you know look back 10 years ago five
years ago 15 years ago and think of a
decision you made
that if you would have made a different
decision you'd have a totally different
life today better or worse i don't know
but totally different right in your case
if you'd stay doing what you're doing
you're a lot of money and still been
miserable right you know uh and probably
your great lady over here be feeling
miserable because she loves you so much
and she'd be filling your misery wanting
to figure out what to do but you made
that decision right
the most important decision you can make
above any on the face of the earth
is deciding that no matter what happens
in your life
no matter what happens you're going to
live in a beautiful state
what the hell does that mean
it means that you're not going to suffer
it means a beautiful state is that
you're going to be happy but that's only
one or you're going to feel creative or
you're going to be passionate or you're
going to be in awe of something or
you're going to feel love any state
that's a beautiful state is really the
core essence of who you are without fear
right
all of our suffering as human beings i
deal with people all the time i
i mentioned you off camera two people i
coached yesterday one's a presidential
candidate and the other one is a rap
superstar right both in the same day
and without naming any names
people that have everything by your
point of view most people's point of
view they have the fame and they have
the love and millions of people love
them and they have great economics
financial freedom and they have homes
and they have they have they have the
fashion they have everything they're the
[ __ ]
i can't tell you how many of them are
miserable right the majority are
miserable i'm not i'm the one who gets
the phone call from the vast majority
when i say miserable they're so used to
it some of them don't even realize
they're miserable right but most do
they get a place where it's like how do
i keep this up how do i keep out doing
myself how do i you know i built these
32 companies how to keep all 32 going
and make them all grow every single year
and that's not how life is right right
and then they worry about what will
people think what will they do so
the decision
to say i am not going to suffer that if
suffering arises pain is one thing
suffering is another suffering is when
you're like
i'll give you an example a friend of
mine is a
very famous indian industrialist
and uh billionaire guy
and he just recently took a sport in
india there's been around 2000 years
that almost every village child plays
and he turned it into a professional
sport no one had ever made a
professional sport two years ago
he invested i don't know i'm making the
number up 20 million dollars in it
in two years the sport is so successful
in india that 500 million people watch
the finals that's amazing two months ago
500 million people right
so half a billion that's you know that's
not an idea and people are saying this
is going to be as big as you know for
them cricket is the ultimate thing right
biggest qriket
so
his team valuation on making the number
up i think it's gone to like a half a
billion dollars in two years from you
know 25 million dollars
and his team is number two in the whole
world right he's got these great players
so i'm with him
and he gets a phone call and he just got
done telling me about this great success
and where it is and how proud he is and
how everyone goes the games and people
are so thrilled that it's just become
this movement in india and he created
he's so proud of it
and he gets this phone call and the
phone call is from his management team
telling him that one of his competitors
has just offered four times as much
money as he was offering to his top
three athletes
who are the core of his whole team
and of course they all took that right
and he was so angry he was like i can't
even believe this i these guys were
working in shops and i brought them here
and i made them a star on national
television and they have no loyalty to
me and he's suffering
and the way you suffer is you focus on
yourself right
suffering comes when we obsess about
ourselves what we're getting or not
getting what we should have done what we
others should have done for us it's the
me me me me me game
you my dear friend and i say this with
no blowing smoke your primary core is a
giver which is why you're prospering
you're not the me me you're like how do
i give more do more share more create
more how do we do a better job for our
clients how do you do a better job for
our internal customers who work with us
our partners your entire life is that
it's why you're prospering and you're
not feeling suffering but when you do
suffer and i promise you do yeah
you correct me if i'm wrong it'll
because you're worrying about something
in the future how's this gonna happen
will this come together suffering can be
worry it could be anger it can be
frustration it's anything that takes you
out of a beautiful state and here's what
people don't get you can end suffering
by stop focusing on yourself and focus
on something you want to serve greater
than yourself your children your wife
your mission your life you can get out
of it in any instant because the nature
of the human mind is to constantly
compare things
your mind is your brain is a two million
year old device and it is not designed
to make you happy it's designed to make
it so designed to make you survive right
and that's why it's always looking for
what's wrong it used to be what's wrong
a saber-toothed tiger so i can protect
myself now people are worried about what
people think about them or do they have
enough money when two-thirds of the
planet lives on two dollars a day right
and you're making 38 thousand dollars
you're rich the poorest of the poor in
our country are considered rich that's
not i'm not saying they should stay that
way right but you can only build on
success
and so my view is if you're watching if
you're listening this my goal would have
you consider something
life is short
we don't know how short it's going to be
but
if you only had a week to live
i bet you wouldn't allow yourself to
suffer over a little crap that makes you
crazy normally i think you would
probably spend time with those you'd
love you would do what you love you'd
take on a sunset you'd smell the air you
were taking everything in those final
moments that you possibly do so my thing
is why wait right right why why why not
just decide
that if i start to suffer i know the
solution because suffering is me
obsessing about me you might say it's
not me i'm worried about my kids because
they're not doing well no you're worried
that you haven't done enough for your
kids it's about you still right yes you
know you're worried about what was done
or what you should have done or what
shouldn't have done and you can end that
in an instant by becoming aware of it
and saying i have made the most
important decision of all right
i'm gonna live in a beautiful state
because here's what's gonna happen
anybody watching you may lose a family
member you probably will
somebody may get cancer
your business may the government might
change the rules they might change
things radically you can't even do
anything about it you
might go bankrupt you might get divorced
i don't say anybody will but no sure no
one knows what's going to really happen
in your life life's full of uncertainty
but here's what you can know you can
decide no matter what happens you can
have a great time if somebody like
victor frankl can be locked up in
auschwitz
and come out of that and experience
finding joy in the middle of auschwitz
then human beings have a capacity
they've undersold themselves on we think
that the outside world determines how we
feel if if people have to behave a
certain way if your husband or your wife
or your kids or your coworkers or
whoever your boss
has to behave a certain way for you to
be happy and if they don't you're
unhappy then you're always going to be
unhappy because the more people around
you the more they're going to change
that because they're all human right and
if you have to be a certain way to be
happy you're going to violate it too so
my invitation is as great as it is to
achieve
more important to enjoy right and if you
can enjoy every moment in that state
when you're feeling loving and playful
and passionate and curious and awe you
treat other people 100 times better when
you're feeling frustrated pissed off
overwhelmed worried stressed or feeling
sorry for yourself you're going to be a
better parent you're going to be a
better lover you're going to be a better
business person you're going to have a
better life so my soliloquy is decide
decide today and actually say what if i
cut it off what if i said i'm not
willing to settle and i'm just going to
live in a beautiful state doesn't mean
you won't feel bad and it means you
won't stay there you instantly change
that's doable i'm on a mission to help
people and suffering i always tell
people the most valuable lesson i got
from my mentor jim rohn was i asked my
father worked two jobs
we were always broke we had no money for
food and we lived in a community we
moved to which was i thought they were
all rich and we were on the other side
of the tracks it was a lower middle
class but compared to where we lived
before these people seem rich compared
to us
and
i just didn't understand it and jim said
to me tony
it's not about the value of your soul
it's about the value of you in the
marketplace and your father's skills are
not that valuable he used to take he was
an underground parking attendant and he
would take people's ticket and make
change well the research now shows is
being done at yale is being done
overseas in england as well and they
found that 40 of all jobs they project
in the next 10 years are going to
disappear because of technology it's
going to be replaced by an algorithm
it's going to change you know all these
guys on wall street you're seeing all
these algorithms take over and they're
getting rid of all these traders right
it's changing radically these in these
hedge funds
there's three million truck drivers
self-driving cars are here in the next
five years they will be the standard
certainly within seven or eight years
are you gonna hire someone who can only
work eight hours a day and sometimes
gets drunk or can make a mistake when
you can buy a machine
right down the machine and be in a
position where it works 24 hours a day
driving but no one is telling these
drivers this and it's they have to
retool now so technology is the biggest
challenge labor is less valuable because
of efficiencies with technology and it's
going to get better and better for
technology which is scary when you think
about what's going to happen for jobs so
i say to people you've got to
participate in your own rescue you've
got to retool yourself the idea that
bernie sanders has of providing free
education sounds wonderful but the
education he wants to do is community
college there are no skill sets in
community colleges today for the most
part that are going to prepare you for
the economy or a job that's there so
what is that going to do you're just
going to waste more money more time we
need to retool ourselves the
government's not going to do it for you
these thoughts that we have we think
there are thoughts so it makes it really
hard to change them and people meditate
and try to not think thoughts
show me some of your thumbnails
successfully consistently if they're
full
everybody the mind thinks thoughts but
here's the distinction
if i told you 100 years ago we're gonna
fly to the moon and back you would have
called me a lunatic that's where the
term comes from people still use it and
it doesn't make any sense because the
lunatic is somebody thought we got the
moon back we've done it right
i didn't know that yeah
that's where it comes from but if i
would have told you 100 years ago
that there's going to be a box in your
pocket and you're going to pull this
thing out you're going to hit a couple
buttons and then it's going to capture
invisible waves that are drifting around
the earth and bring the waves in and
you're going to see somebody on the
other side of the earth and you're going
to talk to them
you're totally nuts
thoughts are those invisible waves
and when you use your body in a certain
way if i sit like this i'm going to
channel i'm going to tap into a
different channel of those waves than if
i'm sitting like this
kind of like a tv set if i turn one
channel it might be a comedy channel i'm
gonna see a lot of laughter turn another
one it's a horror channel turn another
channel it's a romance channel
this is what changes which of those
waves you touch in so if you can start
to realize
that your thoughts do you think are your
thoughts there's nothing unique about
your thoughts they've been around for
thousands of years you're just tapping
into them because of what you're doing
with your body that makes you either
fearful or passionate or courageous or
whatever you're feeling as you go in
those states you get different thoughts
so what i want people to see is they
learn how to just see those thoughts go
by learn how to be entertained by those
thoughts because i have crazy thoughts
and but what i've gotten good at is
going look at that crazy thought that's
not me that's the mind not your mind
because if it's you how do you change
you pretty hard
but i really truly know there's i
haven't heard a thought come out of you
that's original
you call them your thoughts but they're
not you've stolen them they've been
around forever
when you see that it's easier to let go
of them and letting go of those thoughts
is one of the ways that you free
yourself and then again the more you do
it just like a muscle you get better and
better and better and all of a sudden
the [ __ ] that used to make you crazy or
stressed out and like how many things
have you worried about that never came
to be
and some people their life is good so
they worry about other people you know
so they're never not worried right so
it's really just a pattern if you want
wealth
real wealth is not just money it's
emotion
it's like what are we really after in
money you don't have money you want
pieces of paper with the pictures the
deceased notables on it you want what
you think money will give you think
it'll give you freedom or security or
stability or love it won't give you love
it'll get you sex it won't get you a lot
of money right so
really what you're after is the emotion
and so what i want people to get is the
emotion they want now and all it is is a
new habit it's learning to discipline
this mind
right by realizing the mind thoughts are
out there
and letting them float by and constantly
coming back to what can i love about
this what can i appreciate it's like if
you can learn to love or at least
appreciate
start to enjoy
the things that you used to get upset
about
how much freedom would you have how much
more joy you have and i know people got
billions of dollars i've coached them
who's like holy they live in scarcity
all the time one man i'll never forget
he's screaming at his wife i'm in the
media i mean i'm in the house and he's
screaming at his wife because she spent
some money on a bunch of outfits and
stuff like that he's a multi-billionaire
he couldn't spend all his money in his
lifetime and then he's totally upset at
his daughter's in her 20s who spent some
money too and i'm like i pulled him
aside afterwards and i said
what do you do this for
and what do you do it for and he's like
well just it's the principle thing i
said no the principle thing is do you
love these people and do you want them
to have an abundant life
when you have there's you don't have one
loss but you live like you're poor
you know and it's like i finally got
through to them but so many people
that's why i say money doesn't change
you money magnifies who you are
so you want to expand the depth of who
you are and free yourself from suffering
by just knowing it's a pattern of
thought and you can change the pattern
of thought michael gerber the guy that
wrote the e-myth you know talks about
why so many businesses young businesses
fail and one of these things he says is
most people
are not really entrepreneurs but they
think that's what they should be
they think that's the sexy thing that's
the most attractive thing that's the
best answer
and what i say to you is you got to
separate the vehicle from the outcome
what is it that's going to truly fulfill
you what is it that's going to give you
that extraordinary life what's going to
make things magnificent on your terms
not somebody else's terms not your
father your mother your background what
is that really separate the vehicle
because there's many ways to get that
vehicle but i'm saying sometimes you've
got to reevaluate what's going to really
make you fulfill
what is your gift
are you an artist are you the talent can
produce something no one else produces
as a skill or a product or a service or
some impact
are you incredibly good at management
you really know how to manage or lead
people
are you an extraordinary entrepreneur
that has can take that gigantic gut load
of risk
and can create the vision and attract
the talent that you need and the
managers and leaders
you may have all three abilities
but which one really fulfills you the
most
is going to be the critical question
because we tend to want to do them all
especially room like this because you're
all over achievers right me too
and you say well i can do all these yes
you can
but what will it do to your quality of
life
see again the secret's going to be this
what is an extraordinary life on your
terms today what does it take to create
world-class marketing
what is the unique selling proposition
what is what we call value added
marketing vam today
most people are sick and tired of
advertising because where is it
everywhere in fact i got a question for
you
how many of you in this room
do not even see banner ads anymore
literally
it's there but you don't perceive it
like there's like your brain literally
washes it out raise your hand if that's
true keep your hands nice and high and
look around the room right now and
you'll see 98 of the people wash it out
so don't buy them unless you're going to
create something really unique
it's a total waste of your money and
your time in the world we're in today
today
what creates marketing is when you don't
just market but you add value to people
you do something you teach them you give
them an insight you give something
valuable that costs them nothing and
then they look to you as an expert
they look to you as a person that adds
value they want they want you to supply
them more information more experience
more products more services people ask
what does it take to succeed the one
answer i give them is hunger
[Music]
that hunger is the greatest asset that
you'll see in everybody from richard
branson to google or an apple or
facebook these you know giant companies
you got to become a master of your
ability to turn on your determination or
your creativity or your hunger or your
passion or whatever it is it's going to
take for you to get from where you are
to where you really want to be
intelligence is so valuable but there
are so many smart people i can't fight
the weight of a paper bag hunger is that
part of you that says i will not stop so
you really have to decide the most
important decision is do i want to be
happy will i commit to being happy more
importantly than happy
sometimes you'd be so happy to smile so
much your face hurts right you need
variety
am i committed to living in a beautiful
state
even when it doesn't go my way even when
it rains on my parade even when my
biggest fear shows up because i can't
control whether your husband or wife
will live or die or get sick or leave
you or get a divorce i don't want any of
that to happen any human being i hate
suffering i do anything i can help
people not suffer
but i can't control that you can
you can there are people who've lost
their arms lost their sight there have
been people that have been through the
most horrific experiences of life and
they found a way to still be happy
because they've made the decision that
life is too short to suffer i've
interviewed dozens and hundreds over the
years but dozens that like have impacted
my soul that made me realize i can
change this i've just gotten used to it
i've bought into the theory that this
this
survival software
that's constantly running
and making you suffer that that's normal
no that's what the mind will do and mind
has been around forever what i'm going
to do is something different and the way
i get out of suffering
i give myself a 90 second rule it's
really simple i say look if i feel
myself starting to feel that stress
feeling that pissed offness or upsetness
or concern or worry about my kid
whatever i realize that's not going to
make it better life's too short to
suffer and then i just kind of breathe
slowly slow everything down and i just
watched the thought go by and go look at
that crazy thought somebody said crazy
thoughts everybody said i thought i'm
gonna kill that son of a [ __ ] right and
then you don't kill them because you
don't believe that thought
it's the thoughts that are stressful
that you believe that mess you up when
you question them
you break the pattern the more i've done
it's like a muscle the more i've trained
myself to do it i can authentically tell
you now it takes a lot for something to
take more than 90 seconds for me now and
the level of joy
surpasses all the money you could ever
have in a million years and then the
money it's easier to make money because
you're not attached you don't have the
fears you don't have the scarcity that
people have because you feel so rich
already right now i always tell people
don't wait to be rich what is that
richness it's abundance it's joy it's
happiness it's contribution it's getting
out of yourself because as long as we're
thinking about oh my god
i lost something or you did something i
have less love less respect less money
if i think lost less or because you did
something
or because i did something i'm never
going to have what i want in my life
lost less than ever those three thought
patterns
they're the source of all suffering and
the antidote
see it for what it really is know it's
bs
and find something to appreciate most
people who start a business very often
will start two and three four more and
the reason they do it is because the
first one isn't succeeding or they're no
longer the patients exactly right and so
what happens that person is they're
never going to be successful in most
cases unless they get lucky
bounce across something that's easier to
do but most people are always looking
for that next level what my view is is
it's great to test all these things but
you've got to find what is your flagship
what is it that you're going to commit
your soul to because if you don't do
that the inevitable challenge are going
to come up and you're going to then move
on to something 100 enjoyable and so the
other thing to look at is business is
about constantly not only adding such
massive value doing more for others
anybody else but it's also
simultaneously about your own psychology
it's your ability to go through
thresholds of control
um it's like
i can remember when i didn't have 50 000
keep the doors open on my company i had
12 employees and 11 wanted to quit
because they hated the person running
the show
and 50 000 would be like 500 million to
me today and i figured out how to get
through that threshold and once i did
like all the problems related that were
handled i know you've done this as well
and then i you know i had a five million
dollar lawsuit was totally unfair unjust
and i finally had just the amount of
time energy and learning how to bite the
bullet dude 5 million was more than i
could remember then i had a partner
who took a company losing a million
dollars a day and turned into 1.5
billion in positive ebitda i'm not
mentioning names amway
and he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners not doing the
multi-level side did the business put in
10 million bucks we all put in 10
minutes 40 million to debt but i signed
joint and several which i didn't
understand in those days what that meant
and two of my partners were supposedly
billionaires and they went broke we
bought some more companies i ended up
with 120 million dollars in debt that i
was on the hook for no one else had any
money and i'm good enough to do a
seminar wanting to throw up it was a new
threshold of control so you know when
you ski or you snowboard and you think
you're maybe you're just new at it and
you think you're going down a blue or
green it turns out to be a double black
and you're like
yeah
and so you have two choices one is you
start to go down and you freak out
you're gonna die slam on the ground try
to hang on for dear life or the other is
baby you focus on where you want to go
you find a way to curve you find a way
to cut and once you do it a couple of
times you get used to it you have no
more fear of that element now my biggest
one out of that that led me to a billion
i have 31 companies now to give you an
idea seven different industries as
diverse as like uh you know stem cells
to virtual reality we have the exclusive
for the nba now virtually how to give an
example
we do i got 1200 employees we're on
three continents and we got five billion
dollars in sales but i did that because
i first stayed on one freaking thing
exactly i'm so masterful at it there is
another level
the only reason you keep saying there
isn't is you feel so exhausted about
where you are but life the universe or
god is just testing you because there is
another level if this is good giant jump
to excellence giant it's done good poor
to good to excellence
there's a level where all your dreams
are realized
there's a level that you've always
dreamed about it is real it has not gone
away
but it takes that extra burst when you
think there's nothing left there's no
way you've tried everything 10 million
times and you keep going it's almost
like god is saying if you keep hitting
this wall enough times i will see that
you will not stop that you are filled
with that level of determination faith
and courage and then the door opens
and you get to that next level but most
people don't know is
the next level is just
two millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding
what's it called
what's it called
what's it called outstanding magnificent
unstoppable extraordinary not excellent
it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know
what's amazing you only have to be two
millimeters more than everybody else and
you get everything you get the joy the
laughter the fun the family the passion
the economics the freedom the spirit
it's all there what jerry maguire called
the quan baby all of it
and it's just two millimeters above and
most excellent people give up because
they're exhausted and there's some
people go the harder i hit it the more i
hit it sooner or later it's going down
i'm not stopping and when you do that
enough it pops open treat people at the
end of the relationship like it's the
beginning
and there won't be an end
and that's not just your intimate
relationship what if your customers what
if you fell in love with your customers
with your clients more than your product
more than your company
if your entire life is about meeting
their needs if you would do what for
your customers clients you would do what
if you love your customers and clients
you do anything guess what they're gonna
love you but most people love their
customers and clients as long as they
buy from them do what they want respond
to them
and when they don't they go that's the
end
you want clients for life not just
customers fall in love with them
it's a different focus isn't it it's a
different meaning and that creates a
different life because you make
decisions differently from that place
fulfillment is an art
what's going to fulfill you is different
than the other person next you're not
going to learn that from anybody else
and you got to find it because success
without fulfillment is the ultimate
failure and i get those phone calls all
the time for the multi-billionaire
entrepreneur or
politician or business person or a
person just won their academy award and
they're depressed and they can't tell
anybody
because they got all their goals but
they're not fulfilled
because they really don't have that
sense of meaning in their life
they went for something and they got it
they achieved and if you doubt this what
i'm saying is relevant to you or us or
anyone
just think about about a year and what a
month ago we lost
what i consider be a national treasure
robin williams
how many of you loved robin williams
look around the room keep your hands up
look
and most of you didn't know him
almost everywhere you go in the world
people love robin williams by the way
was he great at achievement
oh my god that guy he said he wanted to
make become a great comedian he did that
i want to make the world laugh he did i
want to make my own tv show he did i
wanted the number one tv show he did it
i want to make movies he did i want an
academy award for not being funny
not his skill set drama and he did it i
want a beautiful family he did it and
then he hung himself
make everybody happy about yourself
not a good plan
so if i had a gift to give you
it would be maybe make a different
decision and a decision is
that no matter what happens in your life
you're going to live in a beautiful
state
a beautiful state and that could be
happy that could be grateful that could
be being generous those are all
beautiful states aren't they it could be
curious
it could be fun it could be playful
you're not limited to one state but it's
different than suffering
and most people's suffering and all
suffering i've ever seen i've traveled
100 countries i've dealt with
presence of countries and you know
presidents of businesses ceos i've dealt
with people in prison i've dealt with
you name average people
suffering always comes because you're
obsessed about something related to you
you can only be depressed if you're
focusing on yourself he said no i'm
depressed because it's my kids and and
they're not doing well no you're
depressed because you feel you've failed
your kids it's about you it's about how
you think you what you should have done
or shouldn't have done or what someone
did to you or didn't do to you
in the past or the future which don't
even exist so i have a simple goal my
goal is help people make a decision that
says i don't know what's going to happen
you might get a divorce
even though you don't think so
you might find a family of your family
with cancer
you might have your house get burned
down or have a tornado go by and if you
live in the same place it happens every
two years and you move back we should
talk but
some people seem to do that for some
reason
you can't control those things i can't
control those things i don't want those
to happen to you or anybody i love or
anybody who's even a stranger to me but
they're going to happen true
not positive thinking just the truth so
if that's going to happen i say make a
decision now that says i'm going to live
in a beautiful state and i'm going to
find beauty in whatever life brings me
because life is too short not to so what
do you think was the first real
breakthrough that you had as a teen that
started you on your path and how did you
get there
gosh there's so many
one of the first ones i think was
probably um
just anchoring in when my my mom and my
dad i afforded fathers my mom was a
powerful woman so she kicked my fourth
father out whose name i carry and he
adopted me and when he went out she
decided it wasn't his side so she kicked
me out too by chasing me out with a
knife and i wasn't worried she was going
to stab me or anything but i decided
this is freedom and i've got to find a
way to make my life work but i had no
money at a 1960 volkswagen i worked 40
dollars a week as a janitor to buy and
pay for and so i had no car i had no
money i know anything i went and slept
in a person's uh laundry room and then i
decided i've got to figure out what to
do and i needed to feed my mind because
i was so depressed i was so overwhelmed
i'm missing my brother and sister and
feeling just completely out of sorts so
i i got on the bus and i traveled 14
miles remember because i ended up
running it one time uh and i went to
this bookstore and i bought this book
called the magic of believing by
bristols the first real book other than
maybe think and grow rich or emerson's
essays
and i started on this journey of saying
every single day i'm going to feed my
mind i'm not going to hope good thoughts
show up i'm going to read biographies
i'm going to i'm going to find out what
makes people tick i'm going to
understand what makes me tick and i i
want to read a book a day but i didn't
do that i took a speed reading class and
i read 700 books over seven years and
they're all personal development human
development psychology physiology and
what i try to do is take anything that i
learned and apply it and then when i
applied it you know i was 5-1 in my
sophomore year in high school i'm six
seven now i tell people the difference
is personal growth
but sincerely i
i i became mr solution because i wanted
to help everybody so i was this little
fat guy
and i couldn't lose weight and i lost
weight all my buddies are like how'd you
do that i said well here's what i did
and they lost weight and then we all got
girls
and that led to as a young kid you know
that led to where you know if you had a
problem i was mr solution especially if
you're a girl i was more motivated to
help you so the breakthrough was really
understanding the power of compressing
decades into days that if someone has
spent decades of their life and they
compress it into a book
and you can read it in an hour or a few
days
you have such an advantage because when
you learn by your own experience it's
painful and it's slow when you learn by
other people's experience everybody
knows in the financial world other
people's money is leverage right well
other people's experience is more
powerful than other people's money
because you can have the money and lose
it but if you get the experience you can
change it all so i think that was the
beginning for me and it set me on a
lifelong path of
hunger when you went off on your own you
know that's kind of the point i think
people you know most businesses fail at
the beginning in the first few years so
there you are on your own what do you
think were the keys to success those
first few years by yourself
obsession with adding more value than
anybody else ever dreamed of i mean my
entire
life from the very beginning days was
how do i do more for others than anyone
else on earth how do i give them
experiences that are lasting how do i
create change where change was
impossible how do i take somebody's been
in therapy for seven years in an hour
produce that result and the way i did
that was by challenging traditional
psychologists and psychiatrists and
getting on national radio and saying
give me your worst patient i'll handle
them in an hour which was pretty
abrasive you know as a young kid you can
get by with that stuff but the best part
was i backed it up and so one of the
first interventions i did was in
vancouver british columbia canada i got
on the radio and this psychiatrist got
on the phone and just on the radio live
and just thrashed me you're a liar
you're a charlatan people like you
should not be allowed on the radio
and i said sir i said i said are you a
you know a scientist he said of course
i'm a physician
i said well a scientist would never make
an assumption
and i said you've never met me right now
you've never met my clients now and
you're calling me a liar on national
radio i said she must be stating your
hypothesis
your hypothesis is that i'm a liar in a
charlatan and if you're studying
hypothesis and you're truly a scientist
you got to be willing to test it am i
right yep he goes well yeah it's great
i'm doing a free guest event at the
holiday inn tomorrow night anyone
hearing my voice can come i'm going to
do a series of demonstrations and i'm
going to take one of your clients and
check around i said share with me
somebody that you've never been able to
change i said i'm sure you've got plenty
of those you want to play hard to like
play hardball because well i have
patients that aren't made a change yet i
said i haven't found any because i've
done three therapies total
but i had so much belief it's a long
story short he told me this woman he'd
been working on for seven years
with a snake phobia a phobia is not just
a fear it's an uncontrolled response to
fear so like she dreamed the snake would
bite her on the face and then the
adrenaline would shoot through her body
and wake her up it doesn't happen four
to seven times a night
seven years
so you know he was put in a corner and
so he brought her down and it took me
about 15 minutes at the end of it i
tested first and she's straining and
shaking and then i wrapped the snake
around her
and
that changed my entire career because in
that moment every there was no question
everyone in the audience saw that this
woman is transformed and i said you've
been treated by that psychiatrist for
how many years seven years then i took
on sports stars and then i turned around
you know i did some work with mother
teresa nelson mandela and bill clinton
and as the years went by it just built
and built it up you know you get on an
airplane what's the first thing they say
if we get into trouble mask will come
down oxygen's there and the first thing
you got to do is put it on your kid
right
no why who do they tell you to put it on
yourself your selfish bastard what's the
deal here right but it's because we
don't take care of ourselves we can't
tear them so for leaders what i always
tell them is it's you first it starts
with you and it starts with your
psychology eighty percent of growing a
business if you look at what the
chokehold is on a business
it's always the leader and eighty
percent of that chokehold is the
psychology of twenty percent's the
mechanics i mean people in this room
know the mechanics and strategies beyond
what anybody on earth knows in their
category so it's really about you being
in the state where you execute it's like
i always tell people knowledge is not
power it's total bs knowledge is
potential power execution trumps
knowledge every day of the week and so
my life is how do you get yourself to
execute and execution comes from
learning to put yourself in that right
state every day i believe leadership is
really a skill of influence it is the
most important skill that any human
being can master and i don't think of
leadership as a position i see it as a
skill a tool that all of us have to have
in other words the quality of your life
i really believe comes down to your
level of leadership other people don't
have to follow you to be a leader but
you have to live life on your terms and
the first person you have to influence
is yourself you know whether you're fit
or fat you know whether your kids are
you know on drugs or not is who has more
influence the guy on the street corner
or you with your fit or fat is can you
influence your own hands your own body
your own mind to do what's necessary so
i think to be able to influence the
thoughts the feelings the emotions and
the actions of another human being
that's what leadership is the minimum i
do is i want to know more about my
clients than anybody that they know
about themselves
i know a man that
from australia decided he was a dentist
and he decided he was tired of people
not showing up he was tired of trying to
bill and not getting paid you know
properly from various insurance he was
taught all these things one day he just
decided to sit down with every one of
his patients one-on-one and he said i'm
changing my practice
i'm going to do a practice where i'm
going to take a lot less clients and let
go probably half the clients i have
right now i only want to do business
with people who i personally like who
when they come in i want to sit down
have a cup of tea with them we'll
understand what's going on in their life
what their goals are and i want to make
sure that everything in my psyche is
taking care of them and helping them
augment the way they look the way they
feel and their vitality and the health
of their system and he sat down and said
so to do that i want you to know i have
some simple things i'm promising i'll
give you the best dental care of your
entire life i'm promising that if you
come in your appointment you will not be
delayed in one maximum of five minutes
ever
uh i'm and he laid out all these things
i'll give the best care there's this the
most attention he goes but this is what
i'm going to require for patients that
work with me i'll refer them out to
someone else that this is uncomfortable
is that i require that if they cancel
they're going to have to pay for it i
require they show up on time because i'm
going to respect them they respond me
i'm going to also require that in the
next six months that if i do the quality
work i promise they'll give me two
referrals for two other quality people
that i'd probably want to take care of
as well and he said i'm shutting down
any other form of my business and i'm
gonna spend more quality time with you
and i want the referrals because i don't
want to spend time marketing and selling
i want to spend time putting my
attention and making your life better
he quadrupled his income and cut the
time he spent doing dental work by more
than 60 percent
right just because he became an owner
who owned his business instead of
running around trying to please
everybody and being frustrated people
are canceling and so forth most of us
just don't own ourselves enough right
when something is considered quote
unquote impossible how do you reframe it
so it becomes possible in your mind
and how much of that is mindset
well i i think
um
impossible is not a fact it's an opinion
when someone tells me it's impossible i
always just look
anybody around me knows that they can't
do that that's part of it but if they
didn't know me
it's your opinion and they'll say no
science shows and i see and how many
times the science shows something's
impossible now science shows it's
possible
things are impossible until somebody
does it
and so uh i find that you know most of
your business people you look at
businesses and what does it take to make
a business grow it's not impossible like
a business grow a business been
shrinking for a long time or it's been
stuck
the real problem is always the chokehold
is always the psychology and the skills
of the leader
always and 80
of that is psychology and 20 is the
mechanics like if you don't know how to
read your financials and you're trying
to fly the plane of your your company
i mean come on you know if all you do is
go down you look at profit loss and you
see what it is and you have a beer
either way either celebrated or
depressed you know something
you know you're going to be in trouble
right but if you have the skill sets
that's one thing but you can get any
skill set if you have the psychology and
any time a business is not growing it is
not because it's impossible it's because
they aren't innovating and they're not
innovating because they're believing
it's impossible i mean if we all know
what does it take to transform and
obviously help people take three things
to create a breakthrough in anything and
your personal life and your business
anywhere you need a strategy but that's
not the first place you should look and
it's the first place all of us look me
too it's our inherent thing you want to
lose weight well how do i do it i want
to grow my business how do i do it it's
it's instinctive we've been trained to
think that way but the problem is the
how-to is usually not that complex
i mean come on 70 of america is what 75
of america now is overweight is that
because it's so complex how to be fit
and strong
right you know only the one percent know
the answers they hide it from you you
have to work your ass off to not hear
what it takes right
and so so you know i remember i went to
this uh i went to a ted med center and i
watched about 12 doctors one afternoon
to get up and do these stories about how
we could just get patients to take their
medications and try to figure out the
whole thing and i was just looking and
going you're all talking about strategy
and you've forgotten psychology
because strategy is wonderful i'm a
strategist my whole life figuring out
strategies is we both know a strategy
could save you a decade right and
business strategy could save you you
know you could make the difference
between success and failure
but most people have strategies
available or they could get them or you
could create them but the problem is you
got a story
and your story is why it isn't working
and the story is
i've tried what
what
everything if you tried everything you'd
be fit right
you tried everything you'd be profitable
if you tried everything you'd be there
but people say it you know i'm big bone
that's what i used to say i'm still big
bone but i'm
38 pounds lighter than i was 25 years
ago and i've never gained it back right
when i was big boned that was my story
all the good ones are gone that's why
i'm not in a relationship or they're gay
and i'm not or again they are whatever
the story is
there's always a story and what i tell
people you know if you can just divorce
the story of your limitation and marry
the truth of your unlimited capacity
then the whole game changes i believe in
work-life integration
i don't think um
uh and i'm not being disrespectful
because oh no no yeah i want to hear
that's what i'm saying everybody has a
different metaphor i'm telling you my
metaphor i'm not making somebody wrong
who's focused on balance but to me if
you say balance it's like okay let's use
a teeter-totter or a see-saw okay we're
gonna let's balance it
now now that we've done that how long
are we gonna stand there balancing this
thing before one of us wants to jerk
this thing around just to feel alive
right yeah so i really think
balance is is more about integration for
me
it's more about um
like how do i make sure that i feel like
the areas of my life my wife my children
my grandchildren my health
sports
i got 31 companies we got 1200 employees
and seven radically different industries
we do five billion a year i mean it's so
all these things are going on how do i
do that well
i believe that the way i do that is in
streaks i do streaks of unbelievable
intensity work and i do streaks of like
let go and be in you know paradise and
enjoy and so i like running hot i wanna
i wanna be and have me climb a new
mountain that's just me so i'm not
saying that's right for other people i'm
saying you gotta find what it is but the
idea of balance for most people makes
them torture themselves and i say for me
if it tortures you get rid of it instead
of saying talk about immigration i asked
mary callahan erdos who's if you're not
familiar with her she's probably the
one of if not the smartest person in the
financial world female she's a head of
jp morgan and manages 2.3 trillion with
a t not a b trillion dollars of the
money one of the nicest human beings you
ever meet
breaks all the molds on people in the
financial business there's not an ounce
of manipulation in your body i mean just
good good soul and i asked her about the
ballast thing you're running the biggest
bank in the world right trillions of
dollars
and she said tony i don't believe in it
and she told me where cloud balance i
started we're completing each other's
sentences she has the same philosophy
but her dad used to take her to work and
he was a financial guy when she was a
little girl she used to have her brother
be the secretary and she took her dad's
seat and ran the show
and she said doing that with my dad she
goes i loved it i was a part of his life
i got to be a part of see that part of
his life instead of coming home and me
not knowing it and she said that's what
she's done with her kids and at jp
morgan she leaves and picks her kids up
and she still runs the biggest bank in
the world and builds trillions of
dollars so
would she say it's balance she'd say no
it's not balanced it's integrated she
knows when to move into one or the other
right so that all the parts of her life
are rich maybe instead of balance it's a
rich life in the areas that matter yeah
right rich with your children rich with
your husband or wife
rich with your dear friends rich with
the impact that you want to have your
mission rich in terms of successful
business and or whatever your career is
that you really feel a sense of meaning
and enjoyment if you're tortured by
balance trying to be balanced like other
people oh i'm not balanced enough give
that [ __ ] up
instead enjoy yourself enjoy your
children enjoy the time be where you are
right now that to me is more important
than trying to make everything balanced
because that becomes that gets you
cerebral it makes you evaluate things
the more you evaluate
the less you can actually experience
what's here right now if you look at a
business the choke hold on the growth of
any business is always the psychology
and the skill set of the leader and it's
80 psychology and 20 mechanics meaning
so many small businesses you know
the owner might be an incredible
innovator maybe they write incredible
code maybe they're a tremendous
influencer but they don't know the
economic side of their business right
and they find themselves getting in
trouble because somebody's giving them
financial information after the fact
they don't have true financial
intelligence to make decisions and they
get caught up can you can you give me an
example of a business like that you
don't have to name names no no god
there's i'll pick my own examples i had
several companies early in my career
that were near bankruptcy because i
would sit down and i would i knew how to
produce products that would change
people's lives i knew how to market i
knew how to build teams of people but
what i didn't know was finance so i'd
look and say you know okay how are we
doing oh you got a great you got a 20
profit you know you got two million
dollars in profit those days little tiny
company and i come to the end of the
year there was no cash right i didn't
know that profit is a theory right you
know and so just not having that skill
or someone might be really great in
finance but they're not any good in
marketing so sometimes it's a skill
problem but 80 of it you can solve those
skills you can get those skills if you
can change your psychology but when you
accept that oh my god the market's down
or oh my god the economy in our is down
when you allow the environment to
control your psychology you're not going
to win but also my goal in the book is
really for people to be happy and more
fulfilled
because you can have a ton of money and
still be miserable right you know so
it's it's really it's it's like
mastering the science of achievement but
also the art of fulfillment it's about
if you're totally successful you're not
fulfilled
then what do you have you have nothing
you know you made everybody happy about
yourself uh you know that's the worst
thing you got that's robin williams is a
beautiful man such a beautiful man
killed himself
right and he achieved everything most
people ever dreamed about a beautiful
family you've made the whole world laugh
hundreds of million people love him but
he didn't figure out how to end the
suffering money won't do that most
entrepreneurs are artists in their
nature you know i look at three types of
personalities an artist is somebody that
has a tremendous gift a skill an ability
a talent you know like an athlete uh you
know curry is an as in the indians
incredible artist some people they're
they're artists sales they can sell
iceland eskimos some people it's writing
software they're incredible or designing
clothes
and most businesses are started by an
artist who says i can do it better but
they don't realize that as you start to
try to grow a business uh you're the
most talented employee you have in the
beginning and the cheapest one right and
now you have to hire other people and
you know they're not going to do as good
a job and it ties people into this
negative effect what i really see is the
biggest mistake that these individuals
make is they don't understand business
they get in because they want to do good
work for their client and most of them
as you know 96
are gone in ten years and the four
percent that survive they aren't
necessarily profitable i mean
five percent of all businesses ever
crack a million dollars gross not net
profitability gross
and you have point zero zero zero six so
it's six one hundred six out of a
hundred 000 businesses will ever do 10
million gross
so
it i say to people in business i never
encourage people to get a business i try
to push them away because it's too hard
if you don't have the internal drive to
make it through that psychologically
you're better partnering with somebody
you're better doing something else i
think understanding business is the
challenge and i always say that
80 of the chokehold on the growth of any
business is always the owner the leader
and 80 of that is their psychology and
20 of skills like if you don't have a
market you're in trouble most most
entrepreneurs get in trouble because
they don't know how to read their
financials they don't have a clue i
didn't either you know it's like you can
go out on a plane on a day like today
that's a decent day and you can fly if
you're a pilot with what they call
visual flying world so you can look out
around you and you can fly
you get in a storm you better be able to
read those instruments or you're going
to die
and most entrepreneurs know how to read
those instruments they look down and
they see profit loss and they go oh i
made a profit or i made a loss and they
have a beer either way one to drown out
the pain or the other one to celebrate
right and profit is a theory as you know
accounting is a very special language
and unless you understand
how to use accounting to make better
decisions until you learn to understand
and measure things in a way that gives
you
better decision making capability then
you get broadsided and you know
profitability you get a lot of profit no
cash so i think not understanding the
full aspect of the business
not managing your own psychology and not
knowing your numbers would be three
critical things that i think sabotage
most businesses you can't have a
standard education and expect to have an
extraordinary life it's not going to
happen the one breakthrough for all
leaders is constant never-ending
improvement and that means educating
yourself and continuing to develop even
greater emotional mastery because that's
what affects whether you execute or not
the opportunity for self-education is
there we have to change our psychology
from i'm going to do what everybody else
does and i'm mad because it doesn't work
anymore to the reality is this is the
greatest time to be alive if you're
growing you're learning you're educating
and you're developing valuable skills
instead of complaining you've got to say
where are the skill sets valued in the
marketplace and how do i work harder on
myself than anything else because if i
become more valuable then i will be able
to give more do more and change more
when i interviewed warren buffett asked
the most important investment he ever
made in his life you know what he said
it was i was thinking all the companies
they've done you know he said tony go
into dale carnegie said what he goes
because by developing myself that's the
most important investment those skill
sets learning how to persuade learning
how to speak learning an influence all
my ideas would have died on my lips if i
hadn't been able to influence and i
learned it from that little course most
valuable thing ever did in my life you
said physically stress my body to
extremes because uh i've
developed a process to take people and
help them change in a weekend but my
idea of the weekend is 50 hours and most
people won't sit for a three hour movie
so uh you know that somebody spent 300
million dollars on and i got 12 000
people in a stadium i got back from last
night up in san jose we had four days
and nights like this
and uh we actually had a halter on me
and a group of researchers that worked
with olympic athletes and i burned 9 500
calories in one day in nine hours the
battery died before i finished i i went
12 hours um i did
uh i burned enough calories for two
marathons my jumps because i'm jumping
constantly was the equivalent of two nba
games uh
my lactate as you all know at one is
hard to talk it was 14 and i was still
going strong at 12 hours so there's some
physical stress because i'm a believer
that talking is [ __ ] that you got to
go deep you got to get people to
experience things i think a belief is a
poor substitute for an experience and if
i get someone experience changing
something if i can do it in a really
potent way where they really feel it
then you know if you do that over and
again you start to get someone actually
be trained to get a new result it's not
about belief uh you know belief is
important it's not about confidence i
heard that kind of description that's
never bullets but it's strategy but if
you don't have the certainty you're not
going to execute so i think i've spent a
lifetime accumulating patterns there are
patterns we all have their patterns that
make you angry patterns that make you
sad patterns make you excited patterns
that make you grateful
um patterns in health as you well know
so like all of you who are the best at
what you do i'm massively into pattern
recognition
pattern utilization and pattern creation
and those things help me to create
changes that wouldn't have happened
before if you want more top 10 videos
they're not on this channel anymore i
have a dedicated channel just for it go
check it out the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and i'll
see you there